mugs trash taste mugs you know who's not
a mug you
wow i love this mug i love the lid that
it comes with and how well built it is
and hand crafted the mug is but
unfortunately boys there's only one week
left to get this
i know seven whole days left for you to
grab the trash taste mugs by going to
trashtasmugs.com and once those seven
days are up the mugs are no more i'd
regret it if i didn't have the chance to
buy one of these mugs it's almost the
perfect size mug for any kind of
beverage beer tea coffee water urine
anything you can imagine that you'd like
to drink you can contain in this mug so
if you love trash taste and you want to
support the boys trashtastemugs.com i
would feel like such a mug if i didn't
buy them
one week left get them now links in the
description buy it blind to the episode
hell yeah
just nodded on myself i'm gonna not
what up squad welcome back to another
episode of the trash taste podcast i'm
joey and i'm with the boys and you oh
that was the most depressing intro we've
had yeah what do you mean i'm with the
boys
yeah
you even have any pre-talk there we just
like hey guys i didn't even know i
didn't even know we were recording i was
like oh wait is lights on
rolling are we rolling
i prefer like door the explore energy as
opposed to clockwork orange energy do
you want door of the explore energy all
right i'll give you dora the explorer
energy
hey everybody it's time for trash taste
podcast are you ready
hold on good
hold on i need a bit more time for this
coffee to sink in from uh these amazing
mugs that we're drinking out of right
now a trash taste mug we've already been
promoting them by this point but but we
are actually drinking out of them yeah
we're drinking out of that once and they
have uh these are the the first branch
those the lids a little too big but the
ones that you guys will be drinking from
won't have a big ass lid yeah it will be
the lid would fit a lot better uh but i
i really like these mugs we i mean we've
already promoted them you already know
you already know what we're talking
about we don't know how good or bad it
did
but we're just like
everyone hates them and this is like a
poorly
[Music]
poorly aged episode
but uh it's been roughly two weeks i
think since we all gathered last time
yeah it doesn't it feels a lot longer
like two weeks without the boys jesus i
don't know how i went so long without
seeing you guys so often before we yeah
i moved to japan like well it just feels
like a part of my life has just like
been taken away from me yeah just
because i didn't record a podcast i
think last time i saw connor we were
getting our second shot yeah on my
birthday yeah which was like which felt
like a month ago yeah that was like a
week ago though god how how
yeah
so for the record we've got madonna
shots yeah so did you guys feel anything
for the first shots uh well i had that
like lower back oh yeah we did some
reason didn't we yeah and i was like the
other i mean like obviously like you
know the arm that we got the shot like a
[ __ ] but like for some reason
only aki and i got this like really bad
lower back pain i got out on the second
dose you got on the second yeah my lower
back was hurting doesn't it didn't feel
like someone just like dropped kicked
you in the back he was more like an
uncomfortable like there was someone
like poking my back constantly and i
couldn't i couldn't get it i don't know
why it was mine was like if someone was
like [ __ ] doing that lower back just
constantly
maybe when you and aki are sleeping she
wakes up and just does like wrestlemania
and then vice versa
elbow drops i'm sleeping yeah the lady
bear just invades your dream and just
like
maybe you maybe you passed ladybird in
the hallway
like nightmare on elm street right like
anything he does in your dreams just
like affects you in real life
[Music]
freddy krueger just came out from the
band stabbed me i had a fantastic
birthday celebrating by being sick yeah
yeah
you're like the because we all shared on
like outline uh message that we have
like the how what the temperature of
everyone's was yours was through the
[ __ ] roof you were like yeah you were
like 39 degrees i was like is this the
last time i'm going to see this game
yeah oh [ __ ] i didn't realize it went
that high it was like actually dangerous
levels yeah i didn't i didn't feel like
i was sick when i woke up when i woke up
i was like wow it's just kind of
it's kind of hot isn't
it that's a little bit a little bit
spicy it's kind of what a fever is you
know well i didn't particularly feel bad
i felt i've had fevers before where i
felt really sick yeah i didn't feel good
but this one i was just like wow i'm
just really hot oh really wow and then i
got out of bed and i went to check my
temperature and i was like oh it's
it's high yeah it's oh i'm i'm cooking
from the inside
and then i was like okay i'm gonna go
and get some uh energy drink from the
store not that i'm not energy drink like
gatorade or whatever you know just yeah
generic water so red bull is probably
literally just any drink that's water
featuring sugar uh yeah one of those
drinks
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and i got it
and then by the time i got home i was
like okay no i actually think i feel
sick now
i think i feel pretty shitty yeah and so
i didn't do anything it was the opposite
for me i immediately woke up and like
all of my joints were just
aching like crazy but it was weird
because i checked my temperature and i
only had like 37 or something so i only
had a slight fever but man my bones were
just rattled yeah it was really weird
for me because i woke up and i felt like
completely fine i woke up to like we
have like a group chat where like all
the staff members of trash taste were
just like are we recording today and
everyone posted that temperature and
we're like no we're definitely not
recording today no that's that's not a
thing that's happening and then i took
my temperature and mine was just like 37
on the door and i was like yeah i feel
completely fine and got up started doing
work be like ah these these guys just
have weak immune systems these
yeah things having weak immune systems
and a [ __ ] like two o'clock rolls
over sitting on my computer i'm like oh
i'm getting chills what's what's that
what's happening here what's happening
right yeah yeah and then i went from
like being completely fine to just like
having the worst headache and just
probably just having the flu so i'm just
like man there's a vaccine he's got
hands man it's [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
fighting this has been delayed
yeah it was a bit late so like yeah in
the end i just i i woke up completely
fine and then for like most of the day
after 2 p.m i was just completely
bedridden yeah yeah um how long were you
guys in bed for
i don't know i was watching the olympics
you know just chilling oh yeah just
watching people do sports and i was like
wow i still could be me right i still
haven't seen anything from the olympics
except the opening ceremony i saw that
because yeah we had like a like a little
viewing party at our place yeah because
uh one of our friends really wanted to
see the opening for something to be fair
it's probably like the most interesting
part of the olympics honestly
i mean if you're not into sport right i
feel like you don't even need to be into
sport to be into the olympics oh no like
story lines you know it's a story i mean
sure but like i think for like the
majority of people who aren't into sport
and don't care about the olympics the
opening and ending ceremony probably
like the two biggest highlights of like
the scene i guess i i don't really care
about sports in general i don't i just i
don't know why something about the
olympics is fun it's a thing where
there's just sport that's on all day and
it's changing constantly between events
so you don't have a chance to get bored
like when i've been watching like you
know i might be watching the cycling of
too long i'm like all right okay but
then the next the boxing comes on and i
say oh okay
and then and then you know it keeps
changing and then like okay and i like
what the [ __ ] going on like what is
actually right who's winning
i mean yeah for me the olympics is i've
never been really too
interested in the olympics it's probably
one of my least favorite sporting events
just because there's a bit too much
going on for me like at least no because
we talked about least favorite sporting
events yeah i mean i mean we talked
about stories we lost the olympics
what's worse than the olympics
every other sporting event
i don't know what's better than the
olympia better than olympics well i like
most major sporting events when they're
when the league doesn't count
league doesn't dude league does count on
you i [ __ ] love the league fighter
video games
what am i listening to i love the world
cup i love the euros i love the rugby
world cup as well it's just like it's
for me it's easier to follow along the
storyline if just there's just like one
event or one tournament going on right
with the olympics it's just like what
stage are we at what what sport is this
i don't know i've never even heard of
this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is handball how do i get
invested in handball when i don't even
know the [ __ ] rules
i totally agree with you and so i i
could have watched it on japanese tv
probably is that i don't understand
fully what's being said all the time
yeah and i feel like i realized when
when watching on japanese tv i'm like
wow actually like knowing who the people
are and why i should give a [ __ ] is
actually really important oh yeah yeah i
thought just being able to leave it on
the background that'd be interesting
that's the whole point of commentators
right so and i realized and i so i got
my vpn and i watched it on the british
uh the british uh website did you use
expressvpn i did use accessories hell
yeah
and
yeah i i was watching with the british
commentary and the commentary was really
good and
i didn't realize how much it added to it
because there's some commentary that
he'd be like actually dying like
laughing like uh i think the british
rowing team didn't win like any gold
medals and one of the commentators just
couldn't hold back he was so pissed off
and he was like the absolute state of
british rowing we invested 27 million
pounds in british rowing and we didn't
get a single gold medal and it was just
like live on tv like right after they
just lost and it's like he's just going
in he's like he's like
i felt embarrassed i'm like imagine
you're the rose that made this guy on
bbc go off on one because i don't want a
tyrant
legendary this is like all the other
good sports i don't know anything about
like taekwondo i don't know anything
about but the commentators help explain
everything as you're going and yeah and
it is annoying when you're watching it
for too long because then they start
over again and they start explaining it
again because they assume that people
are only watching for short amounts of
time yeah they because nobody knows what
the hell the rules are yeah yeah it's
great i mean i was watching like diving
as well diving is really fun to watch oh
yeah diving super fun it was really fun
i was like
i think that's the only like sports that
i like in the olympics is like just the
obscure ones that you never get to see
otherwise so it's like with like tennis
and rugby it's like you know that's
playing all year rugby your [ __ ] in the
olympics have you seen it yeah
it's like five minutes aside or
something and there's only like 10
minutes of rugby well most major sports
that have like bigger competitions yeah
are like pretty [ __ ] in the olympics i
feel like like they send like the b team
yeah yeah they don't see you like you
look at like the football or the rugby
or like the tennis yeah
as well yeah oh there's baseball there
so yeah there's baseball yeah it's
basically more like basketball as well
right
yeah like like sports that have like a
competition that's just more prestigious
than the olympics for that specific
sport i feel like it just takes a bit of
the wind out the real magic of the
olympics is watching this small sport
that you've never heard well yeah
because a lot of these sports don't have
any major leagues to you know push them
and give them a lot of money in the
obviously i did see a bit of like the uh
the skateboarding because i was
interested in that i think japan got a
gold medal in it yeah
like it's all kids as well yeah it's
like 10 year old kids yeah i'm like [ __ ]
dude god imagine winning a [ __ ] yeah
right what was i doing in 10 years i
realized the olympics this year has been
awful like every single athlete right he
looks like 30 the interview he's like 21
and he's just won the gold medal i'm
like what the [ __ ] man
this man is built like a greek god and
he's won a medal and he's got he's got
his [ __ ] together yeah
like you you've reached that point where
i you reached that point when you were
when everyone in the olympics is younger
than me yeah no no not even the olympics
or when you grow when you when you're
young everyone you watch on tv is just
older than you yeah and it's just like
something you get used to like every
every athlete every major like
personality is just older than you and
then you get to a point where you start
seeing people that's younger than you
and achieving these amazing achieving
these amazing things and like starting
football i'm like geez like at 21 i was
[ __ ] masturbating and eating cheetos
like i mean well these kids just want a
[ __ ] olympic gold medal yeah i was
getting really pissed off because every
single time they introduce someone
they're just younger than me i'm like
what the [ __ ] is this where's the
where's the 30 year old get it pull it
get him in what does he do he's he's the
veteran
yeah [ __ ] bro the coach is like 27 years
old it's like jesus it's pissing me off
i'm like this is surely surely there has
to be someone age 24 that's why i kind
of almost prefer the winter olympics a
lot of times because i feel that in the
winter olympics there's more of those
like more niche sports that you really
only get to see in the olympics
otherwise you really have to go deep for
it like curling for example is like i
never thought i would care about curling
until i watched the curling like two
winter olympics back and i'm like
damn i want to try this this looks fun
as [ __ ] because i didn't even know the
rules to calling at first i was like
it's just a bunch of people scrubbing
some ice like all right cool so but then
when you actually like learn the
intricacies of the game it's just like
all right that's actually like really
cool i don't understand why like every
country just doesn't agree to take like
a week off during the olympics well to
just sit down and watch it sit down
chill watch it why not every every
country can you know have a week off
seems like the world economy might have
a different a small issue with that
i mean it's like once every what four
years right yeah take a week off
i mean okay dude do you get patriotic at
all during the olympics
i i listen to what the commentators tell
me to do
the commentators tell me i should care
about something i'm like all right i'm
caring do you get patriotic at all about
like any sporting event
oh yeah uh league of legends i want the
eu boys to win well i mean obviously i
was like
again anything else uh for me the world
cup and the euros yeah i was i actually
stayed up i watched the euros and watch
england get beaten this time yeah in the
finals once again good um
and uh
it was it was horrible i had to record
trash taste like the day as well which
is why i was until like four years
remember the last time i recorded trash
this while i was absolutely dead yeah
because i was like watching [ __ ]
england just int
over like whales in rugby i want wales
to win right oh yeah and then if whales
get knocked out of something and england
are still in it it's like okay now i'm
rooting for england to lose
you'd think it would be like you'd think
mostly
the problem is with english people is
that they're the worst when they win at
the sport they like
every time they win it's like every
single country hates them because
they're just they somehow are the worst
country at winning yeah they're like bad
losers yeah or bad winners well it's
just like every single country hates
having the fans in their country
yeah because they're the worst yeah it's
terrible
like like people think because you're
welsh part of great britain well sean in
it you're gonna you've root for england
right and it's the complete [ __ ]
opposite now
except if it's the other way around like
i remember when uh andy murray won
wimbledon it was like it was like
britain's first win in wimbledon floyd
god knows how many years he's like
[ __ ] decades right um and it was like
the only time where like a british like
english people are happy to cheer for
like scottish people because annie
murray scottish i believe yeah um but
they aren't happy to share the other way
around everyone hates english people
right that's true
and normally english people won't cheer
for scottish people welsh people but
when it once is great britain
everything's fine everyone's funny buddy
everyone's buddy buddy again it's team
gb now which is really [ __ ] confusing
because depending on the sport is it's
totally up to the sport whether or not
it's a welsh scottish and english team
right or if it's a
uh a british team or some i think
there's one or two sports where wales
and england are combined but scotland
isn't yeah so it's really
of cool whales scotland is just so
confusing to someone outside of that
country like i've had it explained to me
about three or four times i believe by
you two and i still don't understand
what it is not that complicated i'm like
so what's considered uk what's great
britain what's the commonwealth what's
all this [ __ ] like it's it's just really
confusing to me i mean we do we want to
have we do we the siege watch cbc great
video yeah there's there's plenty of
people just trying to explain it there's
plenty of videos on it we're not going
to explain it yeah
but you should learn that wales exists
and see but at least like you know in
the case with like wales in england
right like at least you got you know i i
feel a lot of the same sports you guys
are either good at or bad at right so
like say for example like in the rugby
right whales in england pretty good yeah
yeah they're not like top top but
they're you know usually stay up near
the top right so like at least you have
that choice yeah i don't have that
choice with my two countries because
sports that australia is good at japan
sucks at sports that japan is good at
australia sucks at
so like in the soccer right like japan's
pretty good australia's [ __ ] in the
cricket japan didn't don't even play
cricket
the same like the rugby is probably like
the only thing because you know i think
last rugby woke up japan came like
eighth i think yeah top eight or
something it was hosted in japan yeah
which is hype as far as right because
japan is never that good um that was the
only time where i was like all right
japan you did good but
we're gonna have to go back to syria now
after that
there's australia they're gonna rugby
yeah australia's really good and they're
in top four yeah i don't watch sports
often mainly because of a it's just you
know we're supposed to live in this time
zone what the [ __ ] when the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] happening the reason why it's so
easy to keep along with the olympics is
because it's just all day yeah yeah it's
great i wake up it's on i go to bed it's
on like
i mean that's kind of what i liked about
big sporting competitions you know any
any age i was where you turn on the tv
and it's just sports playing and it's
just it's just fun and it's fun to watch
something where every match matters to
somebody i just wish i knew more about
who was competing yeah in the olympics
no way you can though yeah there's no
way there's so much information and then
you know even like i was getting
confused because even in like some of
the sports like taekwondo or some of the
martial arts it's like weight divisions
and there's so many weight divisions
there's so many competitors in the
weight divisions and there might be
multiple ones from your country in the
one weight division so it's really hard
to be like all right wait who am i
rooting for what the [ __ ] is going on i
just see the flag and i'm like oh i
recognize that one go that one
that's basically what it boils down to
right it's just like i like my country
let's see that country do well yeah it's
like oh i've never heard of
liechtenstein before i i think they're
good at this sport
they compete in the olympics i don't
even know there's a lot dude like okay
watching the opening ceremony and you
know how they have to like go through
all the countries
there's like over 100 countries that
were competing this year but
it was funny because
they were going not in alphabetical
order yeah they were going in like
japanese like hiragana order which is oh
completely different i was wondering
what kind of order they were going in
yeah they just seemed like the most
weird order yeah that had never been
done that's why there were like you know
some countries starting with c that came
after countries starting with k because
in japanese alphabet it's like in the
same order so like i remember my sister
in australia was texting me because she
was watching it as well and she was like
oh it's really funny because these
australian commentators have been
explaining for the past 10 minutes why
these countries are coming out in this
order they literally have to explain the
japanese writing system to an australian
[ __ ] audience to be like oh so okay
so hear me out this is how it works and
this is why it's the weird order but
like i heard dude there were so many
countries in there where i was like that
that sounds like a made-up word like
that's not a real country some of them
aren't i i i'm correct aren't even
countries like uh i think like some of
them are like micro nations yeah some of
the more uh territories territories are
other countries like there's the cayman
islands as well as listed as this yeah
yeah
i don't think that is
i saw some drama happen live while i was
watching boxing there was like a british
guy versus a french guy
and i mean that's drama already yeah
that's trump already which is that's i
mean let's go back to history
napoleon just makes a [ __ ] like
exposed video or whatever
yeah it was literally like that
and they were boxing right and
so obviously when you're boxing
sometimes you like you did they do the
hugging thing yeah and it's like okay
cool so when they were doing the hugging
thing like i think the french guy was
like head-butting the british guy oh
[ __ ] he like made him bleed and the ref
was like hey don't do that again he did
it again
and then he just immediately
disqualified him right right the french
guy yeah yeah and he had a [ __ ] men
down like a mental breakdown and started
like shouting and stuff going up to all
the cameras being like no i won no i won
into the wow and they were like
announcing it and he was like no stop
announcing it stop it now stop the count
yeah he was like stop this is [ __ ]
there's no way and he was like throwing
a massive fit it was so crazy
how did i not see that i don't know i i
when i when it was happening i was like
oh [ __ ] am i watching drama live yo [ __ ]
yeah i went to i didn't want any good uh
personality
it was great the live league thing
started popping up like midway it was
great
i immediately went to twitter as any
good person would when
featuring drama i was like oh this is
great i went to twitter and i watched it
and i was just watching everyone else
talk about the drama i was watching oh
that's weird because i've seen so many
clips of the olympics there's a lot more
drama in the olympics it happens yeah i
think i've watched more olympics on
twitter than i have on television the
only clips i saw at the olympics was
that they're playing a lot of anime
music yeah a lot of people are doing
anime stuff yeah so when you come out in
boxing you're allowed to play your own
music yeah yeah yeah yeah and some of
them one of them the demon slayer one of
the japanese guys yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
i saw there was a greek person who did
like
yeah i did like year two in one piece
and won the [ __ ] one uh gold medal as
well what a bad i think he said a record
as well so i'm just like yo one piece
stands founder of one piece stands like
[ __ ] stand up yeah the i think one of
the volleyball matches with the japanese
team they'll play in the haikyuu theme
like during like the intervals
and i'm like that's so cool but yeah
like the opening set the only cool part
about the opening ceremony was the fact
that that from what i saw because like
admittedly like compared to some of the
other opening ceremonies that i've seen
it was a very artistic one i'd say yeah
[Applause]
you know what that means it was history
it was very bare bones it was bare bones
like the references i think that people
were looking for were not in the opening
so i think a lot of people are hoping
that it comes out in the ending ceremony
but i think the only cool thing was that
during the time when all of the
countries were coming out because that's
like a like an hour and a half segment
of like all the countries coming yeah
they were playing like just
basically the entire discography of
square enix games like literally every
square enix game you could think of they
were playing the musical so like they
literally opened with like the dragon
quest theme and like they're playing
final fantasy chrono trigger like
[ __ ] near they've played a [ __ ]
near automatic yeah i heard them but not
just any near automata song literally
the most darkest depressing mirror
that plays in like a really sad scene in
the game oh my god i mean it's like
malta and it's just like
[ __ ] like
this
it's really weird but like i'm just
thinking like because you know i think
the biggest question everyone had who
watched the opening is like
where's all the nintendo [ __ ] yeah
that's what i was pokemon where's mario
where's all that stuff that they
promised that like it's kind of odd
because normally japan has been quite
patriotic with all of its especially
pokemon
japan is not
as sweet what's the word uh
japan has not been scared to embrace
pokemon right national symbol and like
you know considering the fact that at
the end of the last olympics yeah the
mario thing yeah like a prime minister
came out of a pipe dressed as mario
right it could be a thing if nintendo
didn't want to do it or it could have
been a thing of or i think what a lot of
people are waiting for is because they
were like square enix we'll let you take
the opening
but nintendo
is the end i don't know
that's why by the time this has come out
we'll know the answer yeah i guess so
but like that's as of right now that's
what i think all the theories are yeah i
mean like do you think the opening was
purposefully done the way it is or is it
just because of the world situation that
they couldn't make it bigger because
that's what i i think i think it's the
latter did you go back and watch other
opening ceremonies i did yeah
the beijing olympics like that one was
insane compared to like japanese i mean
the japanese one was good don't get me
wrong but i definitely did feel that i
think the world situation really did
screw it over in a lot of ways yeah
because i was like
i like the idea that they were going for
but i feel it was like a little
underperformed it's like where's the
budget yeah right
it really did feel like that won't have
the [ __ ] queens yeah yeah yeah i'm
like how much did that cost
yeah that daniel craig be james bond
there's no way he did that for less than
like 50 million exactly he literally
hates james bond
as we've established why would he want
to do that exactly right for queen and
country obviously
that like you know they would have at
least you know some more like notable
like big big people coming out in the
opening right because like that's you
know the way to like open for your
country and like be braggadocios about
your country for years but i feel that
like that's the one time you can
actually brag yeah right and like people
are waiting for you to brag but like i
feel like the references that they did
throw in were like
super [ __ ] subtle and like kind of
offhand or like what was that guy that
was tap dancing i didn't get that
he was literally okay yeah
he was literally i think it was he's
the greatest tap dancer in japan wait to
explain what was going on i watched him
i don't remember that so there was this
tap so what they did instead was instead
of bringing out these like notable names
they brought out like
japan's best
blank so like they had like japan's best
tap dancer and he was performing and
they're like they had japan's best like
jazz pianist yeah i do remember this and
i i think i was like why are they
bringing in tap dances in japan yeah
also during a really like traditional
like wood scene yeah that's why i'm like
this
it's like 400 years of difference
between tap dancing and like edo period
you know
when i think japan i don't think tap
that
i don't think tap dancing in jazz
piano it was just so surreal seeing like
a tap dancer dancing on a stage with
nothing on it to a crowd of zero people
in a stadium that's meant for like
thirty thousand yeah yeah yeah oh it's
so depressing seeing all the studios
yeah i actually read that uh they
the guy who designed like the the actual
stadium
he to make you know because obviously
they couldn't put people into the
stadium so what they did was he
purposely designed the seats and
arranged the colors to make it look like
there were people sitting from a
distance what how can
you [ __ ] didn't that was the intent i
think yeah but uh yeah obviously you
know to varying degrees of success i
mean i think a lot of it was unfortunate
because i i think another thing about
the tap dancing is that it's because the
stadium was so big and i don't think the
microphones were sensitive enough i
could hardly [ __ ] hear it it was at
that point it was just like [ __ ]
stepping with attitude
that's that's kind of what it felt like
the commentators even in the i was
watching on japanese tv they were
explaining what was going on more than
they were letting their audio play yeah
yeah so
how good of an opening ceremony is that
if i need i actually need a narrator to
tell me what's happening like legit some
of the stuff was so avant-garde yeah it
was crazy but like sixty percent of the
commentators were like doing [ __ ]
like audio commentary yeah they were
telling the description exactly what was
going on
this represents blah blah blah and i'm
like just let me watch it shut up just
let me watch it's not very good if i
can't discern what's going on right
exactly yeah i was watching it through
the british commentary and there wasn't
actually much commentary because i think
they were just as confused
it's not a good opening ceremony if you
[ __ ] talk over all of it yeah exactly
i don't go and watch of mice and men and
have someone narrow in my ear what's why
why lenny is doing all this [ __ ] you
know what i mean i don't need this [ __ ]
let it speak for itself that's it's oh
my god i think i think the speech
afterwards of like the olympic committee
actually went on for longer than the
performance yeah
zoned out yeah yeah so yeah i don't know
like maybe that was because of a budget
problem it was because of the world
situation but i mean like i think a lot
more people i think the only good thing
that came out of it was probably square
enix's stocks went
because of like the amount of music they
used at the beginning i wanted to know
how square enix was basically just got
over to got to like take over the
opening ceremony yeah i've noticed
there's so many other like
japanese yeah honestly but they
literally like you know had the actual
spotlight at that point like i remember
as well like it wasn't just square enix
music they literally played a song from
[ __ ] sonic adventure 2.
are you serious there was yeah one of
the songs that played in the scene
because the set piece uh like
was leaked on twitter before the actual
like beginning of that segment and in
the list there was a [ __ ] sonic song
rolling around
i think there's that one
the best opening ceremony of all time
but yeah they literally i don't think it
was sonic adventure 2 it was one of the
sonic games but they legitimately played
a sonic song and i'm just like i mean
sean's pretty [ __ ] iconic i mean hey
man like they did it i guess how did
sega get in and then nintendo just
didn't then i and i think that's why
like that's where the confusion arose of
like okay so like
obviously more people know when you
think of japan from like a foreigner's
perspective you think pokemon and mario
yeah yeah like you don't think of final
fantasy and sonic would you say song is
more famous than final fantasy
it is right sonic yeah probably probably
not weird because he
only had like three good games yeah he's
literally just like he's coming on the
bridge
yeah he's literally cashing in on the
brand recognition he he is sonic is one
of those sonic riders though okay
i recognize that it's not the best game
sonic riders battle adventure 2 is good
and sonic heroes was weirdly good too
but but isn't it strange though how
sonic hasn't had like the biggest
smash hit games yet he's still like the
one of the most recognizable that's the
thing sonic is not purely surviving off
of character design brand recognition
like he's he's just an icon his
character design is poor [ __ ]
it's brilliant
it's just the cult following all right
like you know after sonic uh the uh
sonic 3 all right like we haven't had a
single like goose
well i mean yeah but i mean it's kind of
a remake of it yeah yeah that's up for
debate i mean it's all like been 2d
sonics there hasn't been a good 3d sonic
all the 2d sonics were fantastic
all the 3d sonics except for writers was
you know absolutely trash and yet they
can somehow pump out all these sonic
[ __ ] sonic games and people are still
just like
i mean the next one might be if you
don't play mario and sonic at the
olympic games no i haven't i [ __ ]
lost oh
i've always wanted to play that game on
the 2008
beijing olympics one you couldn't get a
copy of that in the uk it was like solo
everywhere i'm surprised they didn't do
a re-release for this olympics i think
they did last year they did last year
yeah they did last year this episode is
sponsored by apari a paris and artist
owner power brand focused on delivering
clothes with fun color concepts and high
quality fabric the brand features
original art inspired by retro motifs
and japanese animation joey is that some
drip you got on there it sure is gone
i'm wearing a nice summer shirt from
aparri with uh what is this like onion
pigs or something i don't know it's cute
and it's aesthetic damn is that is that
quality fabric right up there there it
sure is it's very is it also artist
owned in original art and it's got a fun
color concept there i said how breezy is
that shirt it is super breezy and if you
look at these photos of me modeling in
the clothes you know how much drip you
can get out of apartment did you know
there's new items for part two of the
summer slash spring collection and
restock of part one is releasing today
at 8 pm est
oh my god and if you missed your chance
the first time this is your second
opportunity to snag something from the
new collection
oh my god and items are limited and
going fast
and don't forget about the ox t-shirt
it's got pigment dyed and a vintage wash
it should feel like a shirt you've
washed and worn for years but don't also
forget about the ox sweater as well and
that the woven graphic of the sweater
just looks aesthetic as hell yeah it
does so don't miss out on new
collections or restocks by following
their instagram at aparri art or by
checking out their mailing list by going
to apari.com links in the description
below back to the episode one thing that
i noticed that uh i saw a lot of
athletes complaining about was how bad
the temperature is here oh yeah how bad
the heat is it's absolutely brutal poor
people doing like triathlons and stuff
and like cross-country cycling and like
it looks great on tv you can't even tell
it looks hot like it just looks like oh
good weather nice yeah it's it's
disgusting here yeah i mean we talked
about this last week but the summer here
is [ __ ] it's insane and just these
poor athletes you have to do like
hour-long events in this heat all right
right now where we are it is 34 degrees
but because of the humidity it feels
like 41 degrees it's insane it doesn't
it do be like that like even just
walking from the train station to the
office like it's a nice like brisk 5-10
minute walk i'm [ __ ] dying time i get
it i don't care where you live or what
[ __ ] temperature it is no one should
be doing sports in 41 [ __ ] celsius no
i should be doing a triathlon
i don't care if you were raised in the
[ __ ] magma crust of this earth i know
there's gonna be one comment who's like
oh it's 50 right [ __ ] off yeah you're
not doing a triathlon 50 degree like oh
my god
yeah i'm wondering how the [ __ ] are they
doing this or how how is like anyone
meant to compete in this weather i
wonder why i'm pretty sure i read
something i could be totally totally
wrong on this one that apparently they
did try and ask uh japan did try and
tell them like hey we should do it in
like september or something yeah the ioc
was like nope no we're doing it in july
and of all the sports that are like
perfect for this heat aka the swimming
is done indoors yeah so it's like no
point
at least do that outside you know feel
good for the athletes
yeah jesus i feel i feel bad now i
didn't even think about that they must
be absolutely dying out there in the
heat dude it's brutal
yeah yeah but like i mean how how how
much is left of the olympics now that we
are i don't know not only what days left
where are we because it's been like it's
only like a two-week event isn't that
yeah we're on like
what yeah yeah [ __ ] or like day 12 or
something i thought it was like i
thought it was like a couple of months
no it has to be done it's like i think
one of the rules in the contract with
the olympics committed to the local
government is that it needs to be done
within like two weeks oh wow and no
longer no less like it has to
why does it feel like every olympics it
lasts so much longer than that i think
because it's just so stacked because you
get so like the hype for it is built up
more than any e3 event tenfold yeah yeah
yeah any gay any no man's sky wishes
that it had this much hype like because
everything in in like you know i've
we've lived in japan for like two years
now right and since day one since you've
been here you've been seeing tokyo 2020
stuff everywhere like
it's it's insane like everything is
tokyo 2020 like you can get a chocolate
bar tokyo 2020s on it for some reason i
don't know why why is this on there we
did actually buy uh some tokyo 2020
merchandise just because like oh think
about it right like it's one of the few
if not the only olympics that has ever
had you know been in this like weird
world situation where it's been delayed
by you yeah right and it's like it's so
like telling of itself like i think aki
bought a tokyo 2020 face mask like that
50 years from now is going to be a great
story to tell
because it's like you know just to say
that like yeah we lived through a time
where there was such like an insane wall
pandemic that we literally had to a
cancelled the olympics for a year but b
everyone had to [ __ ] wear this for
two years i mean it's it's weird right
because i feel like this olympics the
hype just like you talked about the hype
but i just haven't felt the hype at all
because i think i think last year
before covert hit it was the hype was
definitely oh yeah oh yeah yeah it was
definitely but like i think the moment
covered hit and it got pushed back a
year is when and then the hype for cove
had happened yeah and then i think
pretty much the german people just
turned against the olympics and they
were like we don't want it anymore yeah
even though japan is doing exceedingly
well this olympics as well it's great
it's good oh yeah they've won a lot of
gold gold medals already yeah they're
third right now i think oh [ __ ] okay
yeah they're doing very well see i just
haven't been following them along as
much as i used to just because
i don't know just it like the high like
i said the hype just doesn't feel there
obviously in japan because
no japanese people don't want it to
happen for obvious reasons yeah but also
like internationally it just feels like
there's been a lot less
talk about it as well you see like the
odd article you see
it's been a rough year i think i think
yeah also like political situations are
getting rough and you're seeing it in
the olympics as well yeah it's been it's
been in a lot of talks just not for the
right reasons yeah it just feels like
you know at least like
olympics pre i don't know like 2012 2016
maybe not 2016. i don't know didn't feel
as like [ __ ] like politically as well
yeah i think there's a lot of politics
in it now and that always was maybe i
was younger and i didn't realize but it
just yeah it feels uh very tense
yeah yeah i mean the world is you know
in a tense state right now in general so
it definitely just doesn't help
everyone's just on edge now yeah i mean
like it's it's you know everyone loves
the idea of the olympics just like
the every nation gets together and we
just play a bunch of sports differences
yeah put our differences to size and uh
play some
games friendly competitions um and you
know in any other olympics i feel like
that is the case in this olympics it
just feels like nobody really like
everyone's just forgotten to care
because everyone's just like can we just
have the world open back up yeah like
i see the empty seats there it's it's
reminding me that it's still a
depressing situation in the world well
most of the world at least so
i don't know it's it's it's it's been
difficult yeah definitely definitely
just wanted to be how has how has
who has been winning the olympics i have
not been keeping
china's winning right now five well it's
always china and usa at the top right
yeah yeah and then japan and then i
think australia and britain are like
neck and neck yeah like fourth but i i
it's hard to tell what's going to happen
yeah but i mean china and usa normally
always win yeah they're usually the type
and then that's like the the cold
war-esque thing for them where it
matters who wins that yeah that's the
friendly competition unless
apparently
yeah what's the problem yeah what's the
ranking so people should probably have
30 goals okay uh united states of
america 25 volts yeah okay japan number
three with 20 volts nice oh wow
australia 15 volts let's go
uh roc republic
that's right oh that's that's russia
that's russia roc is fifth grade region
six oh okay okay
yes britain isn't doing too well this
olympics well i like that commentator
said man absolute embarrassment for
british foreign absolutely absolutely
that was one of the events that britain
used to win at least somewhat
consistently yeah yeah i mean it's i
feel like it's it's it's part of british
culture what are we calling sports
that's like one of the things where
we're like we actually have like a big
deal about yeah it's like rowing and
cycling right that we usually cycling we
normally have a really good tournament
yeah british people love [ __ ] cycling
for some reason
[Music]
meme where it was like britain invented
sport gives it to other country they
become better and then america's like
invent a sport no one plays it become
number one
that's true that's crazy
american football le mans
have you have you watched the american
football before are you into it at all
no but i i i love watching the drama
around american football it's very good
more drama you know there's always like
there's always documentaries about it i
watch uh
what is it last chance you i think it's
called netflix
it's about like college football and
they get like the
they follow a team and try and get to
win the league and it's just very funny
oh and it's just insane the lengths they
go to get these kids to play football
based on a true story i know it's like
literally you're following them oh it's
like a doggy matrix yeah they just
literally pick a school and follow okay
okay um yeah that's pretty good on
netflix i watched the one thing about
that nfl player who like killed a guy
um what what was an nfl player who like
killed someone
and yeah and these nfl players are crazy
man
like a lot a lot of them are like
they get up to very interesting stuff in
their free time
like killing people yeah yeah
also like the whole thing where they get
like mad concussions from it and they
all like yeah like i've seen that will
smith movie yeah yeah it's pretty rough
isn't it yeah i mean i watched the
uh super i was about to say superb owl
for a second super bowl
super bowl do you feel like it's like
it's like the most foreign thing on it
like to a british person hearing the
word super bowl i'm like what is that
what the hell okay okay so holding up
you hear about this it's a really big
ball so so so there's me watching the
super bowl before i watch i shield 21
and there's watching super bowl after
i've watched
21 which is a football manga um and i
still don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on really really i i kind of get the
rules well you get the rules now i don't
understand how the super bowl is formed
how does it become who who gets to play
in the super bowl what are the rules
well you just follow you follow the lac
and the lcs right that's exactly the
same
yeah they literally based league uh from
like american sports like the super bowl
what about because that's like the final
right i don't know why it's called the
super bowl
it's just one of the playoffs that
sounds good i understand the playoffs
the playoffs make sense maybe it has to
do maybe it has to do with the playoffs
lead to the super bowl so the super bowl
is like the
the name for the final match yeah yeah
yeah yeah british man learns about
american football man i don't know this
is so fun to me but i only know this
because i follow league and league is
based on like american football i think
it has to do with the name of like the
actual like cup you win do you watch
american football oh yeah no that's not
a baltimore i don't know maybe it is i
don't know i mean that's why the ashes
are called the ashes right right
dude
i know more about like the american
sports system than dude i do i do about
cricket so do you watch american
football
i mean i i just i watch the super bowl
and anytime i go to america they're
always watching football every week and
i pretend to care
about it i watch the football in america
when it's on tv i don't like willingly
go watch it but when it's on i'm like
okay that's pretty cool watching like uh
normal uh football uh you know you get
the ads just in the half time yeah yeah
that's when you get the ads yeah no
other ads the 40 minutes is straight
playing yeah so it's really weird and
jarring when i watched american football
and every time there's like an attempt i
think there's an ad and i was like whoa
yeah because there's so many starts and
stuff yeah yeah this is stops and of
course they put ads there but it's just
so jarring i'm like [ __ ] i don't want
to hear about [ __ ] cheetos and bud
light man i just i can't do this like
that's that's literally the two forces
that drive the nfl it was hard to get
invested because every every 10 seconds
there'd be an ad and i was like oh my
god i mean it's just everything is
monetized yeah and also american sports
so watching american tv in american
hotels is really weird as well because
you know we have our ads before the
program starts yeah and in the middle of
the program yeah right and when i was
watching american tv i don't know if
they changed it or what but i was
watching it and
they let the show play for like two
minutes and then they have an ad and
then they have an app yeah and i'm like
what is this what is this youtube video
what is this
what the [ __ ] is this it's more
consistent than a mid-roll it is they
they put like two mid-rolls and two end
rolls because they have they have like
the intro they have like the clickbait
intro yeah uh then they have they have
an ad and then the actual intro to the
show plays uh half the show plays uh ad
second half of the show plays and then
they have an ad and then you know that
there's like an end credit scene or
something like that or i've seen the
plays during the credits so they haven't
had and then an end credit scene and
then it goes on to the next show or
sometimes it's even worse it's sometimes
there's the end the end credits start
rolling that minimizes into a corner and
shows an ad
yeah there's like another one that i've
seen i'm like am i am i watching an end
credit or i'm all watching it i was
watching south park and they played
legitimately like the first two minutes
of the actual episode and then they
played an ad
right and then they played like 20
minutes of the episode nearly near the
end right before the end the other ad
yeah right before the end like i'm like
a minute or two before the show finishes
right yeah and for concludes
and they play an ad and then they play
the the two minutes of the episode and
then they don't have a break or anything
they immediately start the next episode
of south park yeah oh right two minutes
of that play and then they play an ad
again yeah right right and so it's like
it's i was losing my mind i was all in
the wrong i was actually getting so
angry watching south park because i was
like why do they keep putting the ads
like this it feels like i'm being
bombarded i can't think or straight
where is the the clear act of we put an
ad in the middle and before the show
yeah when did this go out the window i
mean it's it's because
viewers are more likely to keep watching
the show right
i know why it is i hate it
i hate it from like an entertainment
standpoint to be like just let me watch
a
clear chunk of this one episode have a
clear moment where you know the episode
ends and the next one begins and that's
where the ad break goes yeah they don't
give you a chance to take a pee break in
between an episode yeah because they're
like oh you might change the channel so
we'll just play it immediately first two
minutes now you can go where did this
change when was it like this i think
it's always been like this in america
has it really yeah i have no idea i mean
ever since every like the first time i
went to america it was like this and i
remember that was one of the first thing
i noticed as well but then you look at
like
how because normally like when you binge
watch american tv shows there's like a
very clear cut of where they put the ads
in and it's just like a weird moment
compared to british tv shows which is
just beginning halfway through the
episode than ending yeah we have really
strict rules on advertising and stuff so
yeah
there's never any overlays or anything
on the t on the program meanwhile
japanese tv is like put as many ads in
as you possibly can every five years
it's so weird the stuff they promote in
japan but then then you remember it's
for elderly people
other people only watch tv so then it
all kind of makes sense like they
advertise like futons all the time
futons yeah the hell kind of shows
you're watching just normal like nhk
they'll just cut to a futon and there's
so
so many uh tele telecall shows oh
telemarketing shows
there's like this entire channel there's
like three marketing shows there's like
three or four channels basically
and it's literally just it's literally
whole yeah whole networks and they're
not like way back they're like four or
five yeah on the the remote and it's
just like a whole network dedicated to
ads and they show you the product then
you can call up yeah it's literally like
oh it's like qvc or imagine if qvc was
like
number five
qvc is number 20 in the uk or something
right like way way down as it should be
it's just ads no one wants to watch that
just think of like if the shamwow guy
was just constantly promoting different
types of shamwow for 24 hours so it's
just an infomercial channel literally an
information there's like three of them
and they're like like the top the
first 10 shows or something yeah
i could be chatting on my ass honestly
there's a lot of them
i mean i can kind of see why there would
be so many infomercial kind of channels
because i don't know like old people
don't use the internet to buy things
yeah they don't know what it is
so when you when you're a kid right
and you had a sick day okay so i
remember i remember i remember as a kid
you know you'd enjoy the fact that you
had a sick day because great i don't
have to go to school but what do you do
so back when i was a kid i did had
nothing but just had television right
yeah so you had the morning tv shows
you had cbbc when i was growing up and
then it was like it was like between
8 a.m to i think around 10 a.m which was
just like brilliant i'm sick i get to
watch tv programs for as long as i stay
home and then 10 a.m hits and then there
is just nothing to [ __ ] watch like
there is nothing on tv at all and i
remember i'd just be like great i guess
i'll just [ __ ] put on kvc then
because there's literally like nothing
else interesting like jeremy kyle back
then you could watch i didn't get jerry
michael i was like a [ __ ]
seven-year-old i loved it i loved the
shouting and stuff and all the people
jumping around i loved it yeah well i
think it's because like during like
weekdays at you know in
the middle of the day yeah the only
people who are watching tv is like
anywhere below eight and anywhere above
80 right because everyone else is at
work or school yeah cause like if i
can't watch something entertaining at
least like watch some like shiny
products that was that's how like my
brain worked right you're like oh if i
can't watch something i mean it'll be
advertised too yeah yeah i may as well
mom we have to get this diamond necklace
the guy on the tv said we get three if
we purchase one
god
because i like i remember seeing all
those like infomercial stuff during
childhood and
even like 10 year old me was watching
and i was like who the [ __ ] buying
this like who's
who is buying this [ __ ] my permanent
favorite thing of those is that like you
know so they're advertising the product
it looks fantastic yeah you're like wow
this is this looks great yeah it's a mop
that cleans my floor and it cleans
itself this is fantastic and you're like
great i'm already sold and you get to
the end it's like but if you act now you
can get not one not two but three extra
mob and you're like whoa this is just
too many mobs i only wanted the one that
now you have a second three and if you
buy now on this exact moment you get two
extra days free shipping it's like all
right this is this is just ridiculous
they keep throwing things in like and if
you pay by card we'll come to your house
and install it for you yeah it's like
whoa whoa whoa and then and then and
then the program will end and then you
can tell they've done this because they
did it all the [ __ ] time they would
record an extra bit after it it clearly
didn't sell well enough whatever yeah
and it would cut you another pit and it
would be like but but [ __ ] that part if
you buy now you'll get five instead of
three only for today yeah it's like what
is good what's going on i'm always
losing my [ __ ] money literally just
like keep adding on [ __ ] and it's always
like it needs to be now that you call it
like before the next thing comes in you
need to so like there's people probably
just like sitting there just like
waiting to call it like there's another
thing
half the time can i call it now because
i was sold before and now now they're
just raising my concerns because this is
now too much this is just like too good
to be true yeah now it's too much this
is way too many products yeah yeah i was
sold on the 50 pan and now you tell me
you're going to include three pens no
way this is a cast iron yeah it should
not be costing ten dollars per pen
including shipping this is rejected
what what's what like set me off was
when they would introduce like when they
would include a product that had like
nothing to do with the product that they
were advertising yeah but they just like
tacked it on for free yeah like where
did this come from
you get the jewelry and now we're
throwing in an extra tenga on top like
well
this is totally unrelated
all this is worth three hundred dollars
but we're selling it for thirty dollars
it's like is it really really
there's no way all of these companies
are making money yeah exactly
i'm pretty sure i saw this thing that
you're tacking on yesterday's commercial
so it clearly didn't sell well you had
like a golden age because like i felt
like there was a time when the products
were actually semi-decent yeah like that
you'd go to the supermarket you'd
actually see the section of yeah as seen
on tv products and there were some of
them actually like pretty good well i
mean like look how much the [ __ ]
shamwell sold right like that started i
think it was just before the internet
was invented so like now you can just
search up whatever product you kind of
need and if not then japan has a whole
store for them it's called [ __ ] daiso
yeah so like you just walk into daiso
and then you just you you you find
products that you never knew you needed
until you walked into this i need a sign
now that just says as seen on dice
like japan is just like the king of
creating these little devices which have
just like exactly one use one very very
specific use that you never thought
about until you see it in the store and
just like wow i guess i guess i do need
like gloves that can like clean
dishes at the same time i like what i
like
there's a lot of stuff i guess i do need
slippers that have like mops on them so
that i can like walk around while
mopping the house
i guess that's a thing it's only 200 yen
[ __ ] it i'll take it yeah why not
meanwhile if i saw that on tv i'll be
like who the [ __ ] is this yeah he's like
who needs some slippers
they also like it's like a 100 yen store
so like less than a dollar even like
it's around a dollar but your standard
and like my favorite thing is that
sometimes in daiso they'll have
the same product but different brands
and they're all the same price i'm just
like what is this like why if you're
gonna if you're gonna have your
competitor right next to you for the
same price and i what i think is the
same quality what is the purpose of this
well there's clearly not much kind of
tradition
there's completely there's obviously not
like
like dragon's den would never work for
japan because you get the ceo of daiso
there and he'll just say yes to every
idea
he's gonna he'll be like i'll put in an
offer i'm putting in an offer just opens
his mouth i'm sold i don't even wanna
hear it
or putting it in my store
i could imagine dragon said in the uk
they would they they have like 10
[ __ ] minutes introducing each other
before they even actually start the
[ __ ] pitch
business cards
[Laughter]
the person pitching would have to go and
[ __ ] pour in water and everything
like it's like they can't even start and
oh my god
jesus they'd have to start with like a
board meeting or something before they
could even get in the room could you
imagine they they
people being pitched would be like no we
know exactly what's happening i want to
see the script of the man pitching
before he pitches it you know it's like
insane
i would love to see it actually but what
i never understood about those shows is
that it's it's just like
it's sold as you know it's these are
very real businesses and very real ideas
that some of them actually going to be
successful and stuff right but like you
you look at some of the people going on
and you're just like okay i've watched
dragons then before or like shark tank
which is the american version right it's
there's there's like a very simple
formula there's like very specific
questions that all the dragons ask every
single [ __ ] time
and somehow 90 of the contestants never
know their [ __ ] numbers like i think
surely that's the first thing you do if
you if you figure out you're going on
dragons denver you're like all right let
me just figure out my [ __ ] profit
margins yeah that's literally the first
thing you should do yeah like what's
your gross like sorry about it
i'm not gross thank you very much
they're like they're asking like what is
your target audience or whatever maybe i
don't know people
[Music]
people with money i saw this water clear
but it may be [ __ ] laughing from the
british one
it's from the guy who's like the worst
he's like so what is he called is he
called tuka tuka
sounds like a breaking bad character
yeah right he's like he's like the guy
who like all the other dragons hate on
the swamp and uh it's just a great
moment he is he's pitching the offer to
them he's like okay so i'm gonna give
you the fifty thousand pounds you asked
for i've seen this for for ninety
percent of the business what and then
the dragons were like so all of the
business so you said you're trying to
buy the business off of him
like what's the remaining ten percent
you can't do anything
i remember so so like the first thing he
was pitching to was like sweat you
you're so who are you giving the money
to and he's like i'm giving the money to
the business and he was like but you own
90 percent of the business
so you're giving the money to yourself
it was so good and all the other dragons
are like what the [ __ ] bro
what the [ __ ] is this
ultimate money laundering
but imagine if you got to accept like
sharp dragons shut up this genie is
going to agree to it
oh my god it's like
like what is this like these supposed to
be professional like
half these sometimes you see the dragons
right you're like
you're not a [ __ ] good businessman
you just got really [ __ ] lucky with
one business and managed to convince
this [ __ ] tv show to let you off yeah
some of them have no [ __ ] idea what
they're doing i swear
they'll be like they'll be like yeah
he's got a multi-million dollar business
then when you think about businesses
multi-million dollar business is
actually not that difficult no
it's yeah because it's it's it's so
stark the contrast between like shark
tank and dragon's den dragon like shark
tank have like mark cuban and like
full-on like [ __ ] billionaires really
really really you really like really
really stupid people yeah super super
[ __ ] wealthy and then compared to
like the dragons it's
it's i think half the dragons are like
pretty successful but they they've had
trouble like keeping the seats filled
right and they always bring in people
and a lot of the time they've had like
businesses they just sold and made like
four million which is obviously a [ __ ]
ton of money nothing me wrong but we're
talking businesses you know it's not
really a good in the business well four
million yeah
i wouldn't say it's a hardcore proven
track record that you know how to run a
business hundred percent you know what i
mean yeah
all right you might have got lucky here
and there you had a good idea it's like
it doesn't prove that you i don't think
that's good enough where you can go on
and start telling people how to run
their businesses you know what i mean
like personally yeah i get it i guess i
i was just kind of like all right okay
all right they'd introduce them maybe
like he made two million dollars off of
his online card business and i'm like
what what is that
what that's never even heard of it's
hardly a business
oh how am i kidding i'm insulting them
two million dollars
child's play i don't know i just when
you when you you know we're talking a
lot of businesses here that's that's not
it's not that much in business well yeah
in the business world it's not that much
yeah yeah yeah in layman's terms it is
well yeah i think that's how the show
works is that so most people watching
the the show in the uk obviously a
million pounds
two million pounds that's [ __ ] insane
yeah most people can't comprehend that
yeah but you know when you work with
some businesses and stuff and you
understand the margins they're working
with that's not that much
but i guess it doesn't matter it's tv at
the end of the day they're not actually
trying to like it's not actually trying
to give good business but it's like a
[ __ ] tv
yeah if they did people would know what
like a [ __ ] their net profit is and
their margins are yeah i swear some of
the british ones are like staged i they
must
no way some of the stuff because there's
one time there there's like a pyramid
scheme come on
on the british tv show like a guy came
in
who just advertised a ponzi scheme right
and they were like
yeah and the dragons were like this
sounds awfully a lot like a pyramid
scheme
this episode is sponsored by boxxu hey
guys come have a closer look at this
what's up would you like some delicious
and tasty snacks straight from japan
snacks straight from japan yes we do
well box who's got you covered oh my god
box is a monthly snack box subscription
service that delivers original
assortments of premium japanese snacks
and tea pairings first time boxing
customers will receive the seasons of
japan box so they could get a taste of
the snacks per season and shipping to
the us is free oh this month we're
celebrating the moon festival just by
many names mid-autumn festival odds kimi
and jugoya the hunger games all of these
indicate the 15th night of the eighth
lunar moon the night of the hops movie i
know that game
look at these usagi no shippo green tea
buns they make my heart go pyeongpyong
[Music]
i got these setochi lemon mochi don't
they look so lemony
and i'm drinking some hoshino hojicha
latte which is delightful so use our
code trash taste 10 and the link in the
description to get 10 off your boxy
subscription thank you to boxer for the
sponsor back to the show you guys play
pokemon unite yet no i haven't
why not because i don't give a [ __ ]
about mothers not true but you do give a
[ __ ] about pokemon yeah but there's uh i
don't know if you've heard but uh
there's about 100 other pokemon games
out there
that i could also play
but uh yeah i don't know like i saw like
a piece of news on twitter i don't know
how true this is but uh like i think it
was like
day two or day three that pokemon unite
came out and the league players were
like oh ho what's this and then they
invaded it and now apparently it's just
full of uh it's either you're versing
children who are eight years old or
you're versing league players
like that sounds like a terrible place
it just sounds like league 2.0 yeah so
i'm like no i like you pokemon but no
thank you yeah the games are either very
fun or not fun at all right you either
get like stomped or you don't as a as a
gamer and a moba player how did you find
it as a toxic gamer how do you feel
toxic playing games yeah as you talk to
gamer i i enjoyed it i didn't like the
fact that i couldn't racially slow
within 10 seconds of getting in the game
uh obviously that was very unfortunate
of course yeah there's no chat feature
there's actually voice chat apparently
is there apparently i don't know how you
could you have to get you have to you
have to hook up the mic through
nintendo's like [ __ ] way of doing it
yeah yeah i saw a voice chat option on
the game oh yeah no i have done that
through animal crossing actually oh and
it does not work so there is a chance
that if you're a league player you could
say something horrible to that
ten-year-old kid right
no i'm kidding obviously but i mean uh
yeah it's it's it's fine it's weird it
it it's it's pokemon but it definitely
feels like it's been developed not by
nintendo right like you can so has it
been developed by nintendo no it's by
tencent oh
of course of course of course it has
like i guess a monopoly on mobas yeah um
yeah it's like it's weird man it's it's
like when you haven't seen that family
member in like 10 years and he comes
back and he's really weird and he's like
yeah i'm the same guy right you're like
no no what is this you're not the same
person you're right right it's like you
know you you boot it up there's there's
gacha there's loot boxes oh that's you
can buy gems it's like oh my god this
isn't pokemon what is this nintendo
micro transaction
yeah nintendo's been real comfortable
with those micro transactions lately
been getting real comfortable with those
loot boxes all right okay yeah i mean
like i haven't played pokemon unite but
i've seen like clips looked into it and
it just it it's so weird where did this
come from was this announced a while ago
because like the the whole idea of like
a pokemon moba is just like
how how did this happen when i think
pokemon i don't think league of legends
dota well i mean pokemon well people
thought of that about pokemon when
[ __ ] pokken came out right like
people are like wait what
pokemon yeah which is a great game now
right but i remember when it was first
announced people were like this looks
horrible this this just i thought it
looked epic when it came out no i
thought it looked epic but i saw a lot
of people who are like that doesn't work
i don't know there's just something sad
there's something sad about seeing
a child's game by nintendo like this
that's just shoved full of these
egregious microtransactions yeah yeah
sure but i mean you know it's whatever
you can have a different opinion on it i
don't really give a [ __ ] i don't
so have you pulled for the gotcha yet uh
yeah techtone i played with a friend of
ours and he was like he was
he was
and he's a he is a
whale that is pretty much his job yeah
and with without love
yeah within five minutes he was like
spend a hundred bucks just spend a
hundred bucks just get everything just
unlock everything he's like and i'm like
no i'm not gonna do that and he's like
i'll give you a hundred bucks just spend
it right now and i was like what the
[ __ ]
this man when it comes to gotcha this
man like loses all sense of money yeah
he has no
he has no way of holding back but i
respect it you know oh yeah of course
but i i just didn't want it because i
could tell that i i i ended up spending
like 40 bucks on it and i was like i'm
not going to play this again but i'm
going to do it so i can play ranked
right is it free to play yeah okay
there's there's an excuse it can't
there's no
i was
you said you spent 40 bucks which is
like free to play is the road to losing
items you can buy that'll uh boost your
stats in-game
so you can actually it's not it's kind
of like the way to win
the way it was explained to me and i the
way i understand it is that you know how
like league of legends used to have a
thing called runes yeah that
weren't pay to win they would give you
an edge but you could unlock them
through the game yeah but
they give you
a noticeable advantage i'd say at times
um but would you like back in the days
you to buy runes remember yeah would you
have described ruins as pay to win back
then it's kind of like that i mean it's
like
with the advantages that roon runes gave
back in the day you wouldn't be able to
take advantage of that small stat
increase unless you unless you're at
like the [ __ ] higher tier it's kind
of like he's truly optimized the games
just came out and no one no one's been
had the time to underground to get this
stuff so if you do just buy it you do
get an advantage it's not massive but
you get an advantage um i don't know how
big it is i mean from what i understand
it's not that much it is i mean
obviously any advantages should be a big
no-no in video games i think yeah yeah
but especially a children's game as well
it's like you know what's next [ __ ]
tetris with the microphone's actions in
it like well i mean you know technically
speaking that's it's not the first
pokemon game with micro transactions
right i remember pokemon go back in the
day yeah and even then i felt like that
was like it's weird man yeah it's
strange i feel like nintendo they're
like well if another company develops it
it's not us
that is true that's true pokemon was
also not them yeah but they don't but
then nintendo also does weird other
microtransactions or uh brand
partnerships like they're [ __ ]
mercedes and mario kart 8. oh yeah yeah
yeah mercedes
what was going on with that what how did
what what i thought it was like a joke
that someone at the dev team threw in
then i realized oh no it's an actual
brand like
how did this happen what's going on and
she battles me i mean i pick it up every
time i play mario kart just because it's
hilarious yeah it looks so stupid baby
mario in a mercedes yeah just a full
mercedes
i've never played mario kart 8 so i this
is the first time i'm hearing it's like
a dead ass
three mercedes cars and it's just it's
just hilarious to see baby
i don't know
it's just in the game in the game always
since release it's not even like an
unlockable it's just there by default
you can just pick a mercedes if you want
what yeah you didn't know this i thought
you guys were membing
it's a straight up mercedes
what the [ __ ] is going on
like when you select the car as well it
literally says mercedes where does this
fit in the [ __ ] mario lore how how
did this happen well you know if you
know mario was like i'm sick of going
through all these levels let me just hop
in my mercedes
over all the enemies
you know at least ea you know you're
getting into you know i mean nintendo i
can't figure out what the [ __ ] they're
trying to do i don't know what they're
doing everything they're trying to do
everything man this is bizarre yeah i
mean i get it whatever i mean good on
them i guess man i just think i get that
grinder get that coin man i just think
unfortunately like uh microtransactions
is just like kind of creeping its way
into the future of gaming because it's
just yeah it was just sad because
nintendo obviously was the one company
that for a long time was like no i don't
know yeah
but then now they're like yes yes yes
yes yeah
because like genji's come along and just
prove like how much [ __ ] money there
is to spend on anime wi-fi apparently
yeah it's like it's it's ridiculous
because i remember i watched the uh i
watched the live stream of the new
genshin announcement for like the 2.0 in
azuba where they announced the new area
and i think it was getting like almost
400 000 people 400 000 people on twitch
on twitch not youtube twitch live
concurrent which is like how much does
like press conferences on on like ea or
like press conference like e3 and stuff
get it's not that much like 100 100k max
yeah it gets like 100k 200k maybe like
this again shin update
stream was getting 400k viewers
concurrent on twitch which might be the
[ __ ] is going on which mind you or a lot
of the stuff that they announced had
already been leaked
as well so it's like people are like
tuning in to like look at lead ship i
mean like it's confirmed i guess yeah i
mean i i'm sure if i was a fan i would
get behind the high field yeah i'd be
very happy for it
i mean yeah i mean you know obviously it
did very well for them right like yeah
but yeah it just blew me away because
like i was like oh there's a game
shooting stream happening yeah 400 000
people
sitting there waiting for a [ __ ]
update like are you serious and now
more gacha
yes
more waifus
yeah i mean like i haven't haven't
gotten back into against you and i've
been thinking about it because of a new
area but you know even like out of the
three of us the person who was most of
the integrity was probably me and now
she's like that's this is a lot of
people watching an anime anime waifu
game right now could you imagine if like
[ __ ] like if like fake grand order
had an update and there was 400 000
people like watching i don't know
don't do that to me
don't give me hope
is genji in like is it
i'm sorry is it majority played on
mobile or pc i'm assuming pc i'm
it would be more majority pc i mean i
think so right yeah because i i i did
not have a fun time playing gen channel
mobile um at all i think i think some
people just played on both like when
they're home they're playing on pc but
sometimes you know they got to get on
that grind while on the go well i think
i think that's
one of like the biggest advantages that
genshin has over like a lot of triple a
games which is the fact that it's so
[ __ ] easy to play yeah you know you
you literally like every account is
linked and now you can like even link
your ps4 account to like every other
account so it's just it just makes it
like ridiculous is it on the switch as
well it's not yes
it does it does i mean is it on the
switch yeah and apparently there's a
full
[Laughter]
this is the problem when i'm a fan of a
lot of things i also end up promoting
unfortunately i've fully disconnected
myself from gaming hype i don't get
hyped about games anymore i don't know
if that means no happiness for me but
i've i've just stopped getting hyped and
i've stopped watching announcements i
think i've just stopped getting hyped
about things in general because i've
just
because like
that's a little
because i've ran into so many situations
where i just get hyped and i either
experience hype fatigue
or
fatigue
fatigue
so i had to experience height fatigue or
i just
end up getting disappointed with the
final result right and i'm just like oh
well then what the [ __ ] you know give me
back my hype all right yeah so now let
me pack my
still waiting for my cyberpunk hype
refund like i'm i'm firmly of the
mindset you should never pre-order a
game ever no no never no no matter how
good or 100 it looks like amazing or the
bonus deals don't do it it's a bad
practice and i think it's bad for gaming
it is here we go here we go for gaming
man it's sharks
i mean it's it because like i'm not into
gaming as much as i used to be and even
back then i just i don't think i've ever
pre-ordered a game or at least like i
think the only game i ever tried
pre-ordering was gta but that was just
like because it was gta oh yeah do you
remember like it was like 2 000 picture
2013 everything is a pre-order bonus
yeah literally like everything is
pre-order like no everyone is
pre-ordering everything that's just how
it is you pre-order [ __ ] everything
but luckily now everyone's chilled out
but it was insane but i also think kind
of back then it made more sense right
because back then the game you're buying
on the day was the game you were getting
right there was no updates no patches no
nothing and it also made more sense
because we it's just i think it really
hit its peak right before
maybe just during online shopping
started popping up yeah right right you
know and this is before when you didn't
really want to download it because
people's internet speeds probably
weren't good enough to really get
download a full 20 gigabyte game yeah
like that but now you know people's
internet speeds it's not really a
problem yeah and also back then i feel
like you just had a lot less choice of
what games you could play you know as a
kid i'm just like yeah i waited like
four [ __ ] five months for the new
mario game because there was nothing
else to look forward to there was
literally nothing to fulfill that void i
couldn't i couldn't get a free-to-play
game like genji
playing games
like fortnite or league of legends or
anything like that there's nothing to
fill that fill up that void the only
games that i've pre-ordered are the ones
that like i know 100 i'm going to love
i've ordered every single like mario
release of late and i haven't played any
of them
well that sounds like your problem i
don't know why
because i think the last game i
pre-ordered was uh final fantasy 7r but
i 100 of that because i knew i was going
to like it because i liked the original
and like persona 5 royal as well i
pre-ordered that because yeah i liked
the personified i mean i i've i have so
many [ __ ] games that i've bought in
my library that i just have
i've downloaded them i've installed them
and i just never know for them
i've never opened the last time you got
really hyped for a game
final fantasy 7r probably did it live up
to your hive yeah 100 percent of it what
you gone was that fantastic game and it
got very exciting i haven't pre-ordered
it like the last time i got hyped for a
game cyberpunk
i'm not joking that was the last time
[Music]
because i was just like great it's a
sci-fi game it's cyberpunk this looks
like everything i've ever wanted to fill
up that void that mass effect has just
left for let me left me for years and
now that hole is even deeper and now the
hole is ashamed
of therapy with it as well
i mean
i'm like every few months i just google
it's cyberpunk 2077
i saw it i saw a good i saw a good
article it was like cyberpunk is nowhere
near a no man's sky turn around
oh
the devs are like we're nowhere near
fixing it like no man's sky
or something like that according to
something like that i was really it was
just how they said they had to say a no
man's sky turn around of course i mean
that that is like no man's sky is the
[ __ ] anime redemption of the gaming
industry i think it's like one of the
only redemptions that's when the
antagonist turned into the protagonist
because most companies you just cut your
losses and you're like [ __ ] it make the
next [ __ ] fallout yeah yeah [ __ ] 76
make a new one yeah you know it's it's
when was the last time you got hyped
yeah as the gamer
borderlands three i was very hot for
borderlands throughout that was a good
okay uh no all right i was extremely
hyped for borderlands i absolutely
borderlands two is one of my favorite
games yeah because i was gonna ask i've
never played three but i played two
great i haven't played board once what
was the sigh they're gone i just i just
realized i just realized what the game
before okay well cyberpunk 2077 what the
last game i was hyped before that i
bought lens too right i loved
borderlands uh so i bought borderlands
one originally on the xbox 360. right
and uh i thought it was [ __ ] i hated it
because i didn't have friends to play
with so it was terrible game to play
alone but when i finally went back to it
months later my friends bought it went
on more more sale i just went cheaper
sorry uh and yeah i loved it i thought
wow this okay this game is actually sick
when you play it with friends then
borderlands 2 came out and it looked
like they just improved everything yeah
and they did yeah and it was amazing
bought lens 2 is such a good game and
playing it with friends is like amazing
like this this game is so much replay
value with friends um and i absolutely
had like some of the best gaming
memories playing borderlands 2. so
naturally borderlands 3 was coming out
and i had a monster gaming pc yeah i was
ready every all my friends were getting
it there's endless people i could play
with it was going to be good yeah
so i play it and uh yeah it's just kind
of like borderlands 2 but with like a
worse story like the stuff they add
isn't very good wait since when have you
[ __ ] cared about story well
borderlands 2 actually was such like
handsome jack is such an uh engaging
villain oh yeah
[Applause]
he's there always making you laugh right
and that was something that even if i
didn't care what was happening i knew
that i liked handsome jack and then he
was funny as [ __ ] yeah i loved having
that and the and the two main villains
were like youtubers or twitch streamers
in the third one right and it was just
cringe because i'm a youtuber and twitch
streamer right so it was cringe watching
that i am the bad guy
it was like yeah
it was just like poking fun at me in
like the worst way right and i was like
this isn't this isn't the representation
i asked for
this is slander
i'm all down for when people make fun of
youtubers and twitch streamers i'm all
down for it but sometimes they do it in
like a like a way
in a way that you've clearly never
watched something because there are so
many other things you could have gone
for like you know they do the whole
thing of like oh hi guys whatever and
they could have gone for like why don't
you thank me for like the 10 donation or
something like that right that would
have been funny as [ __ ] you know like bo
burnham did a great parody of it i mean
bye-bye used to be a youtuber oh yeah
obviously he did a great parody of
twitch streamers and stuff and that was
great but i felt like it was a terrible
parody and it was also they were just so
unlikable and there was so many bugs in
it as well like there were so many
game-breaking bugs that just happened
throughout and i was like this shouldn't
be happening i waited years for this i
got hyped for this i felt invested in
give my high back i didn't really like
any of the characters that you could
play as yeah which kind of sucked
borderlands 2 i felt like every single
character was like pog yeah
because like the game i think the game
the game i got hyped for before
cyberpunk
was uh this this just shows my track
record and why i don't get hyped for
games anymore right it was mass effect
andromeda i thought you might say
fallout 76 yeah i thought you might say
i thought you were saying this guy
fallout 76 mass effect andromeda
i love donkey's video i don't know i've
never played masturbate i've just
watched these videos on them
andromeda was so funny i think i've
played like an hour of mass effect
andromeda and i'm just like this this
this just isn't doing it for me right
like
by that point like i i think i think
cyberpunk was just uh yeah this looks
like a game that could be you know could
appeal to me but i think mass effect was
really what just killed my soul right
right there's something so
heartbreaking about it in a way that
i've never experienced when a game just
lets you down like that yeah yeah it
feels like your dad just never came home
you know like it's like damn but it's
like it feels like your dad came home
but with a different woman
this
is i don't know it's just it's i feel
like that's the first time you get to
really experience betrayal as a young
adult yeah
a true betrayal i trusted you yeah i
followed you all the way through and
this is how you repay me i stuck with
you for years i had memories with you
that i can't i can't i've never even had
with anyone else and this
yeah it's gone like that yeah
yeah i mean like i i just i just like
now i just try to keep as little
knowledge of the gaming industry and
like what's coming out sports well
because
and it was [ __ ] amazing oh yeah
horizon zero dawn i was like what the
[ __ ] what what kind of game franchise is
this i had no idea what it was about it
was [ __ ] amazing that's why i'm not
hyping myself up for breath of the wild
too right because i don't want a [ __ ]
andromeda to happen you know like god
forbid it never happens but like you
never know right so i'm just gonna like
i'm just gonna wait
and also like i you know i've seen
someone streaming a lot now um
you know when e3 happens or nintendo
press conference i was like did you
watch it did you watch the e3 conference
why would i watch an hour of ads why
what so i can get excited and give my
money to a company that's going to let
me down no no thank you i'll when the
game comes out and i hear it's good i'll
buy it
why would i sit down and watch an hour
conference of getting myself hyped for
something that i probably won't be hype
about i know i think it's pretty fun i'm
not even sometimes sometimes i'm just
like sometimes when like i still
remember um when final fantasy 7 remake
was announced and just the reaction
around that i'm just like i haven't i
don't give a [ __ ] about final fantasy
but i'm [ __ ] hype
meanwhile me who never played final
fantasy i'm like what's going on
meanwhile i was the one guy like
in the crowd yeah and then they
announced like shenmue three afterwards
i was like what kind of press conference
is this like i think i was more hyped
about the press conference than the
actual games themselves
that turned out to be a great game huh
no but i feel like it's a little it's
it's a fun little you know um event you
know if you're if you take part of it i
just feel like you just want to get
hyped it's like the nintendo directs
right that's like another one where it's
just like did you watch it did you watch
the nintendo ds there's something about
nintendo directx that really pissed me
off i can't put my finger on it i get
angry watching nintendo directly well i
don't know why i think it's the way they
present games that clearly no one gives
a [ __ ] about they'll be like and now
it's just dance 17 and it's like
why but they always they always have to
sandwich it between two big titles right
yeah which is like you know fair enough
right there clearly no but it's also
just like i don't care about just
dancing sometimes they do like ad spots
i think for other companies to like
where they give i think it's i think
it's an ad spot i think they do this and
they'll show a game that looks awful for
like 30 minutes and they'll just like a
play through and i'm like stop this stop
this right now
show me an ad show me an ad over this
please
anything else other than this i can't
stand this show me a bloodline ad
i'll take it i'll take a bottle out give
me fallout 76 demo or something god damn
it please i'm begging for something else
i don't know i
i
i don't know i i think i'm just getting
to that point in my life where i'm
becoming extremely bitter about
everything that makes other people happy
welcome to adult things i think i think
i'm getting this it's called being
adulting and it's called being british
as well it's like the worst combination
of angry
i think i sit there on my porch just
like rocking my chair thinking oh you
young kids getting excited over games
how naive imagine imagine being happy
imagine being excited if only i could
feel these emotions anymore oh you think
mario golf is going to be fun really
have fun playing mario
one time at a party and then never
playing it ever again
mario tennis you thought that was fun i
felt i never felt angrier than when i
bought mario tennis the new mario tennis
right it's [ __ ] terrible game you
played it yeah i like it it's terrible
it's terrible why is it terrible wait
have you played the original look no oh
that's probably why
why why i have to have prerequisite
knowledge of another game well compared
to the original it's much better
i love the original i like the original
two but i think the new one just
improved on i mean i love the original
because i was a kid and i had yeah zero
taste in video games everything
i'm sure i'm sure oh sorry i don't have
tasted
i'm sure i pissed people off saying it's
terrible i just i played it and i should
i was so bored out of my mind to playing
this game i mean clearly it's just not a
game made for you right why why is it
not i would have loved this what's going
on what's going on why do i don't why do
i hate this game you sound like the same
crowd it's not toxic enough you sound
like the same crowd of people who are
pissed off when nintendo released like
the nintendo 2ds which was intended for
like five year olds
i thought it was affordable and uh yeah
i like the ergonomics of it it looked
cool it looked like a [ __ ] like
fisher-price like yeah i like children's
toy and adults are like what the [ __ ]
nintendo how dare you not make it
how dare you make a toy
company i'm not one of those people who
gets angry at nintendo for not making
adult-oriented products right that's not
that what they do right but you know
stuff like pokemon i wish that they
would put a difficulty option or
something where you could add something
like like that i wish they would include
something the toxic game right
right now
you know what is that insane of me to
ask pokemon to include like something
that makes it more
into it that allowed you to make it more
difficult or to do certain things i just
i don't understand no i don't i don't i
don't think i
disagree with that because like i think
like purposely leaving it open-ended to
like how difficult you want it is what
makes that game so appealing to people
yeah if you put a difficulty like if you
went into a pokemon game and you were
like choose the difficulty immediately
people will be like uh
actually actually
in regards to difficulty i [ __ ] hate
choosing difficulty i hate it
so much it depends on the game it
depends on the game because unlike so
some games it's it's completely stupid
necessary right like first person
shooters like i hate it because it just
makes them more spongy yeah that's all
it does but on some games like pokemon
where it's like okay this
even even a 12 year old probably find
this too easy like especially the number
one the new one was like the new ones
like hold your hand that's why it was
like beyond mine like even like you know
you you play players that's that's
that's the problem with the game itself
right right i feel like i feel like this
is a game design yeah i feel like even
adding 10 more difficulty to this is
like what like it's pokemon platinum i
was playing that i did another log but
like even the core game itself was
actually kind of challenging like it's
not it's not you can't just like fall
asleep and just spam one pokemon well
that's the thing right it's like i feel
that's the problem with just like
pokemon games in general where like like
i played sun and moon right that [ __ ]
holds your hand the entire
even as an adult and i'm like dude like
10 year old me was crying trying to get
past like gym three of silver right but
and the game couldn't give a [ __ ] like
it was just like just get good it's like
figure it out yeah you're ten you should
start thinking bro stop thinking [ __ ]
ten years
exactly i feel like nowadays people
people have less patience when it comes
to completing games yeah there's no
there's no way making a pokemon gym
slightly harder is hardly asking for
like like it's not we're not even dark
souls level of difficulties
i'm just you know there is you should in
a pokemon game i think even if you're
like 10 years old you should fail the
first gym probably and be forced to be
like maybe i should buy some potions
yeah maybe i should consider doing
something not just [ __ ] steamrolling
this [ __ ] with my mudkip every time just
give it like good game design so that
you don't have to say anything to get
the player to figure it out right yeah
it's like you know i i just
even like when you're when i was like a
much younger kid you know when i was 10
whatever playing these games i hated it
when games were like completely like
steamrolly like you could just do it
without thinking yeah it's like having
some form of difficulty there is good
and it's also important i think for the
kid to learn
everything is going to be [ __ ] easy
yeah exactly like i remember like when i
was [ __ ] like eight years old playing
mega man 2 for the first time yeah and i
was like this is [ __ ] impossible like
no one can beat this [ __ ] love that
game though it's one of my favorite
games of all time because i learned to
like i learned success through failure
kids have it too easy now these guys
is that as an adult i have absolutely
zero patience for games that are
[ __ ] hard right kids do not kids
will play the [ __ ] oh yeah yeah over
and over and over again because it's one
it's probably the only game they're
getting yeah and also there's nothing
it's not that's that's that's that's
what i'm trying it's not an email that's
that's what i mean that's the point i'm
trying right yeah no because i feel like
there's just games are a lot more
affordable nowadays yeah back then you
had one game every few months maybe
but it's still most if they're getting
like an xbox or something okay yeah they
can play fortnite for free on it but if
they want to buy another game and it's
difficult they're probably gonna try and
complete it because they bought the game
when they wanted it for christmas or
something right adults try to understand
kids
i'm just thinking from my perspective i
don't know maybe maybe i mean most of
them are just happy with like fortnite
and stuff right yeah
but i mean
i think the other thing as well is that
at least with like the old games is that
you know because they could only be
so long that they literally had to be
like all right this game if you blast
through it yeah you could probably
complete in less than an hour exactly
but like we want you to play this game
for a long time so we're just gonna make
it [ __ ] hard to the point where 40
minutes of gameplay is going to take you
about 40 days oh there are a lot of
[ __ ] moments in a lot of older games
oh yeah and i i remember thinking back
and i'm thinking how the [ __ ] did i like
play so many like levels of battle toad
and controversy
i did play battletoads it's actually a
really fun game oh it's a good game yeah
it's a [ __ ] great game
like to this day as like i remember
playing the [ __ ] motorbike
like the
i think i played it like for a full week
yeah in my room trying to complete that
[ __ ] level yeah because because i
remember beating mega man 2
lots of times as a kid yeah and then i
recently played it a couple of years ago
i could barely get past [ __ ] wood man
yeah i'm like how the [ __ ] did i do this
as a tenure oh it's because i literally
spent like a month of my life just
grinding also i couldn't play megaman of
my age i'm going to get a [ __ ]
carpool tunnel like i i tried playing
man x i'm just like oh i'm getting a
[ __ ] crap here if i'm just like
doing like the wall jump jesus christ my
god
that's great though i love it i i guess
i'm i guess i'm angry that i'm getting
older and these children games aren't
getting older with me yeah i guess so i
i mean i like with difficulty i like i
i've i i now like when a game has just
like one set difficulty even if it's
like i i i
i'm so like i get anxious that with any
game or any piece of media where i want
to enjoy it the most right i want i
wanted to enjoy the most on my first
playthrough and sometimes i've had games
where i loaded up and i hit i hit the
difficulty level selection and i'm just
like
i'm getting anxiety just now i'm already
getting anxiety you know what maybe i'll
play this game another time this is why
i like games uh even if they have
difficulty options they let you just
change it on the fly yeah yeah yeah i
like the consequences for it and it's
like all right well this cut this
section's kind of [ __ ] i'm gonna
knock it down how do you feel about
people who like purposely select like
easy mode
well like what it depends on the game
there's some games where i'm like you're
actually just like not playing the game
if you pick right because it's far too
easy but like there's that whole like
stigma i i guess like connotation
they're like oh you're not you're not a
real gamer if you're playing it on
youtube good scrub like levels of things
but i mean it's
obviously if i was there in the room
with them i'd be like almost wrong
little baby you're not gonna i'm not
gonna click normal but you know
on the on the podcast and if if a
general audience asked me i'd be like
yeah of course well can you pick pick
whatever difficulty you want yeah right
but obviously if you're my mate i'm
going to i'm going to play play baby
mode mario oh yeah yeah i'm like you
playing america
no you're not no no
no no no no no no no
i mean it's different right actually
you'll poke fun at your friends yeah
[ __ ] around with that but i obviously in
general i think that you can play
whatever [ __ ] difficulty you want all
right
why would it why would i can why does
take away from me just have fun just
have fun if you want to be a little baby
[ __ ] you could be a little baby [ __ ] i
don't care you have the right to do that
you paid the strength you have the right
to be a baby [ __ ] you pay for 60 bucks
you get to do it yeah you know
also you know i think it's it's good
because not everyone you know obviously
some people have disabilities as well
they can't play the game on the hardest
difficulty
they can't do it you know i just think
accessibility is good in gaming i think
that one of the things that pisses me
off most and it's always the japanese
game companies that do this is that like
the accessibility options in their games
are terrible like they don't they don't
let you change anything no button
remapping none of that i love it when
games are like bro what do you want to
do what do you how big do you want the
the character models to be or what now
about so how bold you want the outlines
to do do you ever use button remapping
yeah all the time i really i i've never
used it in my life i love button
remapping and i i it pisses me off that
a lot of games don't do it and a lot of
the indie devs are normally the ones who
include a [ __ ] ton of accessibility
options that's a lot of like pc games as
well yeah like it's not not a lot of
console games have but yeah happening
right i mean the the beauty of console
games is that it's just plug and play
it's very simple you just put a disc in
or whatever or do you download the game
and then you just start playing okay so
the the argument behind accessibility
options and button remapping especially
is like um especially with people who
are you know maybe someone has a
disability where they can't use one of
their hands properly and maybe there's a
button where they can't press jump yeah
but they can press the jump button with
this finger right so the idea is that
even though yes this is probably the
best layout someone might out there
might have a waysier time with this
button being on this this one right so
just give them the option to remap no no
no why wouldn't you yeah no i'm
definitely not against
i've just personally never used it yet
yeah nintendo's got a lot better at it
as well i think actually i think so uh
but they're awkward sometimes with it um
and also like colorblind options uh the
last of us had like amazing uh
accessibility options like you could uh
you could change it so all the
everything in the thing was just like
two colors like it's all gray and the
models are just like bright red and
bright blue so even someone who's like
completely like you know has really bad
uh case of vision can play the game
because they can see the models outlined
and then you can also just turn stuff on
for yourself like you if you if you
prefer color like a lot of people play
apex legends with like the color blind
settings on to change the color of the
bars and stuff to make it more visible
right you know i just i i i think that
especially oh another one okay so i'm
going on a round now this is one thing
that i think is there's absolutely no
excuse why this shouldn't be an option
on every single video game subtitles why
is there not subtitles in every single
video game yeah they have the script i
hate it i hate it like i hate games i
agree with that i hate games that don't
have subtitles like
sometimes i don't want to have to like
listen to it at full volume yeah and
sometimes maybe there's explosions and
[ __ ] going on i want to read it they
have the script just plop this [ __ ] in
it just it's just like what is it about
not just gaming but like movie audio
mixing
especially if you like i remember i
watched uh nightcrawlers yesterday with
sydney and um you know it's uh it's we
watched a few movies and
we were we turned up like the tv to
almost full volume yeah characters start
speaking which is like
like what
what is that subtitle option and then we
turn on the tv to full volume and it's
still like
i literally had that happen to me when i
watched interstellar like last week
like oh my god it's a fantastic movie
don't get me wrong but my god and i love
matthew mcconaughey but man like like
listening to him is like listening to a
subwoofer that barely works
this is like
because when they're mixing these movies
they're mixing them on like these
gigantic audio editing suites yeah you
can hear everything i'm like no edit
this [ __ ] on a [ __ ] uh airpod bro so
you can hear what most people are going
to listen to like one when they're when
they're listening to them like it's this
amazing scene you know when like matthew
mcconaughey is giving this like really
like intense speech yeah and all i'm
hearing is just these [ __ ] organs and
it's just like
that man he's like
i don't know what you're saying
speak up
because like i said some of the time
like the audio mixing on like video
games as well it's just it's it's like
watching a bass boosted meme you know
where the dialogue
is like so
quiet
your ears get [ __ ] destroyed but i
[ __ ] love youtube videos so like
small youtubers he's like audio is way
too [ __ ] quiet and the music is like
done
you can't [ __ ] hear them and i don't
know why i love it it's my favorite it's
so charming i know it's so pure i love
it but yeah subtitles on video games
this is why this is why we need it even
like especially even in your own
language right yeah yeah so yeah there
should be absolutely no reason why they
shouldn't be subtitles these have to
write the script to the game just put
the [ __ ] script into the software
that can do this yeah right just yeah
someone has to time it
and i hate how it's like a lot of games
the default is off yeah yeah yeah just
make it on yeah and if you don't like it
then you can turn it off also i think a
lot of games is why i'll do this and i
think every game should do this is that
they let you choose how big you want the
text the color of the text the outline
of the text shadow and stuff so you can
get the subtitles just right so you know
again if you're if you have if you can't
really see very well you know you should
i don't understand why games don't just
give you all these options i get it it's
crunch they don't have time but i mean
it's like all right well just [ __ ] the
people who can't play the game like
everyone else right just [ __ ] them right
yeah [ __ ] them
which is why like everyone loves to
clown on xbox and and i get it you know
i'm an xbox boy myself i love xbox yeah
i think xbox have done some of the like
most amazing things for accessibility
have you seen the um the controller
they've made
it's like the it's like this pad right
and you can literally hook anything up
to it right literally anything into a
controller and it's set up so that like
you can just turn anything into a
controller so that no matter how your
position is or what disability you have
you can set it up so that you can get
away where you can play games oh that's
cool and it's like they have so many
mods with it as well so you they have
in-built mods but you could do anything
it's so cool it's uh can you pull it up
naby actually was it called oh you're
talking about the coffee actually real
quick yeah okay this episode is
sponsored by zen market a gentleman have
you ever come across an exclusive piece
of anime emotion you could only get in
japan and you want this so bad that it
kills you i'm glad i'm alive because i'm
here in japan so i'm not being killed
because we have lovely stuff like the
exclusive jojo suits and the jojo watch
which joey is wearing right now i wear
it every day that's how exclusive it is
and there's a badass junji into hand
pedi bags you can't get but you could
have gone if you'd gone to zen market
earlier and you see these exclusive glam
shirts
only ship to japan like this oscar shirt
and basically the jojo shirts which we
wear every other episode would you want
to get one well gentlemen worry no more
because the sponsor for today's episode
zen market
with zen market there's no need to live
in japan or even know any nihongo that's
me because zen market takes care of
everything for you all you have to do is
place an order with any japanese online
store and zen market will receive your
item shipping it wherever you live using
your choice of international courier
only a flat fee of 300 yen per item
three that's like three dollars you're
basically living in japan also for a
limited time of two weeks they are
holding a summer discount for all of
their customers where each one of you
can get a one-time 25 discount of
international shipping by using the
coupon code zen 25 during checkout
getting all these juicy exclusive anime
and manga goodies has never been this
easy delicious so what are you waiting
for go over to our very own trash taste
landing page link in the description
down below and start exploring japanese
snacks clothing and electronics and so
much more today back to the episode yeah
xbox made this controller called the uh
xbox adaptive controller and like you
can literally just plug anything you
want like a massive button something
that you blow on like so cool literally
anything you want so like recent oh it's
been out for like two three years oh wow
threat for a while never heard of it and
uh it's done some amazing things like
it's it's so cool that like xbox thought
to do that because they're probably not
gonna make much money off that right
yeah that's not something you make money
off of so a lot of the companies won't
do it but you know i thought [ __ ] fair
play to microsoft man like i mean yeah
like that's great cred right yeah i i
just like why wouldn't you do that
they're looking out for all gamers out
there yeah and uh also you know just a
lot of
the term gamers has just like been
reporting
for the record i meant that in all
sincerity all right please
any any any game company or whatever
that spends money and time to develop
stuff for you know uh accessibility
options that they know is probably not
going to be valued by 99 people yeah
that's mad respect yeah of course well i
i feel like you're praised i feel like
in terms of customization and
accessibility well not maybe not
accessibility but definitely
customization it's always been the pc
gaming crowd that's been like leading
leading the charge and you know
obviously xbox microsoft you know it's
it kind of kind of feels like it fits
within their ip whereas nintendo is kind
of like the apple of the gaming world
where she's like this is how we're doing
things and
you can buy a peripherals you you can't
buy your improv rules it's also gonna be
operational it sucks right because like
imagine it like miyamoto's there this
kid who can't use his hands and mimo's
like yeah you don't get to play my games
why because you don't make enough money
to make money do you millions of dollars
no bye-bye you know like it's just like
why would you deny someone the option to
play your games you know like i'd like
to think that if something happened to
me or you know uh if i had a kid who
loved gaming and and he wasn't able to
use the standard controller
i'd want to think that there's a chance
that he can play his favorite games
i said he like i know it's a boy of
course it's gonna be a boy
i won't allow it
girls
disgusting you know i i just gave you a
girlfriend
they don't exist
[Music]
it's not hard to make something that's
like that that you can just allow
someone to customize you know obviously
you still need help from someone else to
help set it up for you but yeah you know
what i mean i don't know why why not
pisses me off yeah why not like they all
these companies have all this money
right like at least spend it on
something that you know like nintendo at
one point yeah i think a year ago it was
the most cash cash rich company in japan
i mean did that pandemic did they have
been watching
cash lying around make a [ __ ]
accessible controller nintendo [ __ ] me
stop making joy-cons that don't [ __ ]
work
god damn it i'm making joycons that
break after six months jesus
it literally is like an apple periphery
it is like oh breaks off the system
let's just just buy a new pair it's
about a friend who is like
he didn't know anything about joycon
drift
and they were like yeah i don't know how
much joycon drift you don't know
anything about joey i obviously don't
play my uh it's when that's enough it's
when the d-pad just does so
unfortunately there's a massive lawsuit
going on i don't know if it's been
resolved with nintendo and a bunch it's
a class action um essentially the
controllers after like a random period
of time they just start drifting the
joy-con like the the joysticks
right it's not just the joy-cons either
the pro controllers do the same thing
yeah and it's been a massive problem and
people have to buy so many joy-cons and
drinks aren't cheap they're like 60
bucks yeah 67 it's ridiculous and um
yeah and they just they drift and i had
a friend who was playing it
and bless them they not really a gamer
and they were like yeah so when i'm
playing it sometimes i just go to the
side why is that i'm like first time
yes so nintendo made a shitty product
that doesn't [ __ ] work so you have to
deal with it buy a new one if you don't
like it spend more money yeah nintendo
says they'll fix it as well then they
have like warranty
i think the last thing that something
like that happened to me was uh the
infamous xbox red rings of death oh yeah
bro that was such a debacle
what a [ __ ] clown fiesta that was man
did you have to send your xbox away to
microsoft no no so like i i did this
like [ __ ] gorilla tactic that i found
on the internet of like now now that i
know what i'm doing i was just basically
overheating the xbox so what you do is
you [ __ ] wrap a towel around it and
then no i'm actually serious
you wrap a towel around it and then you
turn on the xbox and leave it for like a
few hours so you're just basically over
here
yeah you're overheating and cooking your
[ __ ] cpu or something you think it's
like a 4chan thread to set your house on
fire
like what the [ __ ] yeah very very much
like a uh fire hazard but first
arsonist for some reason for some
inexplicable reason it worked and i have
no idea why wait wait so do you want to
explain what the red ring of death is
for people who don't know
um so back when xbox released their xbox
360. they rushed it out and it was
poorly manufactured yeah had many
problems right so if you bought one of
the first consoles first generation
consoles that were released um you
basically had a time limit right it was
basically like a year or two and every
xbox had this where you play and then
one day for one reason that nobody could
tell it just wouldn't work right and so
you would get the three rings right so
when the xbox turned when the xbox turns
on right you would um you'd see like a
green ring around the power button yeah
yeah yeah and basically there were it
was split into four segments and
uh the red rings of death meant three
segments were red which was mean
something was wrong with the startup
right and
nobody like we called it the red rings
of death because everyone had this issue
i know and it never got resolved and how
you would resolve it is to basically
send it back to the manufacturer they
cost microsoft billions yes because of
all this [ __ ] because it happened so
often right and my friend i had two
friends about it so we had a group of
four of us who all played xbox yeah and
i never got it thank god i would have
actually cried because what my friend
had to go through sounded like my worst
nightmare as a 16 year old me yeah he he
got the red ring of death and he had to
send it back and then they sent back a
box that an xbox that was refurbished it
was someone else's and it didn't work
yeah what so and again like this so
they're just recycling xboxes apparently
they had they were doing stuff like this
like it was pretty widespread so you
sent it and they called them up again
this is like over months like this took
i think it took like half a year to get
it fixed overall he had sent about like
three times before they finally fixed it
and then and then it broke six months
later and he just gave up he was like
i'm not doing it again yeah i'm not
sending it out
i mean this is that that literally like
scared me to death i was like the
thought of my xbox dying i was like this
is my only this is my lifeline like if
this goes what am i gonna do i don't
know what i'm gonna do if i can't play
halo reach i'm gonna lose it
it's gonna be everyone's problem
dreamer memory cards yeah stuff have you
ever had like a save file that's just
been corrupt
actually trauma on my childhood of like
my [ __ ] gamecube ones just like dying
for no reason
back in the day mad cats was like
everything like if you wanted a
controller or another memory card or any
peripheral yeah that was half the price
mad cats so like we have the we have
like the xbox now and now uh not the
xbox sorry the gamecube in our room
right now and i was like okay i got to
buy some memory cards for it i just and
like the trauma kicked back the moment i
said that to myself i was like we got to
buy memory cards we got to buy memory
cards i just ended up buying like 10
memory cards because i was like i'm just
expecting the worst yeah one of these
memory cards gonna die in like two days
guaranteed luckily it hasn't happened
yet so i just have this like pile of
memory cards in my room that are just
unused just in case but yeah yeah i
remember it was it sucked as well
because it was like there was no pattern
to it no there wasn't there was never it
was just like one day the memory card
was like
stay up yeah
yeah i think playing with memory cards
uh on the gamecube has given me a
permanent fear of playing jrpgs like
like it was like you know
mario kart you know [ __ ] any zelda
game okay zelda's bad enough okay yeah
oh dude like i've had some wind waker
accounts just completely dying on me for
no reason but there is nothing worse
than a [ __ ] jrpg corrupting and i've
had it i've had on gamecube i've had it
on ps2 i still have never finished star
ocean three because i've gotten [ __ ]
60 hours into the game i was invested
and then the memory card got corrupted
and i just lost 60 hours of my life i i
and i've never gotten it back and i
don't know what the ending of that game
is i i i had it even worse once i think
it was like the the second time i played
uh a final fantasy game i was playing
final fantasy 6 for the first time on
super nintendo and i was like 40 hours
in i think i was like maybe like two
bosses away
and uh and just one of my cousins walked
past kicked the snes it completely reset
completely reset my file what the hell
it's like a light tap like that
it just went
just died and i was like
what happened flicked it back on
corrupt all gone yeah and i was like i i
had i've never been that close to
committing murder in my life
but i was that close like eight-year-old
mia was like
is this how like serial murders start
joey was a good boy until the day
until he wasn't until that day when
someone kicked his ass
and then i realized and then that's when
i realized just the
absolute fragility of these like old
consoles that literally just a tiny it
wasn't even like a boot it was like
literally just like a little like it was
it was either you you had like an
absolute tank or you got very unlucky
and one tap did it like i i swear to god
i dropped my nintendo ds like a million
times a child oh dude those things are
brick [ __ ] houses yeah but i heard yeah
but somehow you know my my ps2 would
just [ __ ] itself all the time
but i swear everyone else's ps2 was a
tank so i i don't really like like for
some reason like they're always like the
sony ones well just like the most
fragile things compared like being a
nintendo switch 360s i've seen like how
how those things survive i don't even
know man even though the red ring of
death like yeah yeah yeah like
i know like do you remember did you ever
have that experience on a ps2 where you
you know you go up to the loading screen
and then you put it the disc in and you
just like you're praying for like a few
seconds of silence you're praying to god
that you're gonna get the
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and yeah it's and when you don't you
have this like it's like this [ __ ]
hellish dimension right where where the
ps2 just turns into like the gates of
like the [ __ ] gates of hell opened up
it's all red you're just like oh i've
got a corrupt disk oh no
how do you even do that how do you get a
corrupt disk how does that even happen
how do you not do that i'm sure have you
never have you never opened like had a
had a full og like xboxes like if that
was like one
like micro meter oh actually oh they're
being scratched yeah no not even a
scratch if there's like just a tiny bit
of dust on it it just wouldn't run i
remember there was like disc cleaning
services at like game stores
and uh really yeah yeah in the uk and
they just didn't [ __ ] work like at
all like you paid like 30 pounds yeah
which is like the cost of a game at that
time right and you'd get like two
disspec and then she didn't didn't do
anything it didn't work they'd be like
yeah it's good to go i'm like no it's
not i put it in did you even try it no
yeah it worked i'm like coffee didn't
that's why i like the you know like the
super nintendo cartridges right because
it's like if it didn't work cartridges
are pretty nice wall on that [ __ ] like
smack it against the wall if you want
you pop it in and it magically works oh
so
speaking of the cartridges things you
should never do yeah um i remember how
like i had a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like it was like you know you
know some kids are just [ __ ] yeah
absolutely no reason yeah so we had like
this uh we had like this distant
relative friend who like yeah she's no
longer a friend no no no you you'll hear
this
you'll hear the story and you're like
you know you know family or unions
especially asian family unions they're
like some kids there some people that
you don't know how you're related to all
your families related to but it's like a
family friend cousin and they're always
[ __ ] worse so i remember we were like
playing goldeneye on the n64 he only
chose our job didn't he huh but he chose
no no no no he didn't no no no he he he
didn't do that uh he he got he got
smacked he got smashed he got batted and
he was a pretty good scorer yeah we we
scored him it was four before it was uh
it was a four player game yeah he died
immediately yeah and he he got
humiliated and what did he do
he just went over to the n64 and just
took the cartridge out
no
no turning off the console no nothing
just took the cartridge that's a big
no-no you can't do that
i'm just like i'm just like you know you
know the you know the debate of like
whether people can be born evil
like i'm just like clearly kids are born
evil like i'm clearly just witnessing
johann lieber right here there are some
kids that you're like you you
you must have been born for something
wrong you came out the womb of boston i
bet there was [ __ ] music playing when
you came out the [ __ ]
like final fantasy boss music yeah
it's like for some like as a kid as i'm
sure you can understand as well like
yeah as a gaming kid right there was
like you could punch me you could you
could spit on me you could stamp me but
you don't touch the game console no
that's a big no no you don't doesn't
matter how heated [ __ ] gets you stay
away from the people that's sacrilegious
that's like that's like the stuff that
you i was i was a calm kid at times but
the one thing that would set me off like
you touched the game console while it's
on that's yeah i'm a loser i don't care
who you are yeah one of my biggest pet
peeves as a kid whenever i play with
like a mate or something or whenever i
have mates over is for some reason
everyone had [ __ ] greasy hands and
their controllers would grease up their
hands would grease up
ps2 controller yeah like like my biggest
pet peeve was when you know when we were
having food or something and we had
pizza and they would they would be
eating the pizza while playing the game
and i could say
get a wet wipe please
and i could see their greasy hands going
on the controller and i'm just like you
know what maybe friendship's overrated
this this is why i played the forms
of grease in like in between like the
button and the yeah
like physically see it that's why you
know when people grab pizza and there is
kitchen all available i'm like you
absolute animal why didn't you that was
a perfectly good kitchen roll on the
table why do you not take a slice yeah
you know for the crumbs or just to wipe
your hands on you know this is pizza
it's greasy come on
yeah please please learn some manners
especially as adults because i feel like
even even as adults there's some people
who don't do that as well and i don't
know greasy controllers are just like
one of my biggest pet peeves yeah that's
pretty disgusting because it's kind of
hard to clean it yeah it is
i was gonna say something i totally
forgot
you know what was my my most hated genre
of video online it is like yeah genre of
video it is the people who turn people's
game consoles off of like 10 year old
kids while they're playing and they're
like look he's getting angry yeah no
[ __ ] he's getting angry you just turn
that [ __ ] off i've never heard of that
genre of videos you know you must have
seen them there's tons of videos out
there where people just go up to like
their little brother turn the game
console off or pc off while they're
playing minecraft or something what a
cut and then and then they're like haha
look he's getting angry yeah no [ __ ]
he's getting angry he's probably
building his [ __ ] world yeah that's
like the adulting version of that is
like if your friend was driving and then
you just pulled the [ __ ] keys i was
like oh look he's angry yeah no [ __ ] he
it might as well be [ __ ] life
it's one of those things where it's like
okay
doing something to like
if that kid actually turned off his own
pc that's funny you know if he gets
angry yeah this is his fault he did yeah
but when you do to someone you know it's
like okay just because you don't
understand the hobby and you don't
understand how invested someone is [ __ ]
you thinking that it's just funny
because you oh you're here you turned
off you've got a reaction do something
else what's wrong with you this is what
it's like especially when it's like
unwarranted right yeah how sad is your
life that you have to do this to someone
that you have to just turn their game
console off to get some views on
instagram or something like [ __ ] off
ridiculed yeah where have you started
seeing me yeah these things have been
around for decades online i think i've
just like avoided watching them some of
the like most popular clips back in the
day were like brothers turning off each
other's game consoles while they were
playing and like watching their kid rage
i mean the only ones that's a big thing
i mean the only one i know is like the
kid who got like his uh wow account
deleted by his mom right yeah he's like
freaking out oh that's staged there yeah
yeah that's stage but i feel like i've
seen some videos where that's been true
or just you've seen it yeah i've seen
i've seen some of those videos where
just accounts get deleted but like
because obviously now because two talk
is
rising right so i feel like two talk has
been going through a lot of the old
trends that happened back in the day
yeah and i've been seeing it a lot on
tick tock and i'm like this isn't funny
this is just a [ __ ] like how are you
getting likes for this what was it funny
back in the day though when you're
watching it
but yeah but that's because like the
kids would like stage it and they would
like make these like insane reactions
funny back in the day when i was younger
yeah when i was i'm older now now
there's just a dick when i was 10 i
thought it was funny because i was like
oh this is great this is so funny the
kids shouting and screaming yeah and now
now i'm an adult and i'm like but then
seeing
another adult do it i'm like what's
wrong with you if my if you know if i'm
10 and my childhood brother did it to me
that's probably funny to another 12 year
old me
one one like video genre is very similar
to that that i just i've just never
gotten or found funny it's just like
people being [ __ ] in like big
stores or something so like it's like i
remember i used to see all the time in
vine and tick tock or something like
that i don't know how many tick tocks
yeah i started being dickens
just just like [ __ ]
just being public nuisance just being
public nuisances in like it's always
like something like a walmart or a
holiday like used to like the milk
challenge or they'd throw the milk in
the air yeah throw the milk in the air
or [ __ ] just like get get all the
footballs and just like start throwing
them everywhere or just like breaking
[ __ ] and it always like it was always be
captioned with like the [ __ ] laugh
emoji or something like that i'm just
like who's who's funny someone's got to
clean up this mess because there's
always someone making a mess or
something i'm just like dude like the
[ __ ] employees are getting paid [ __ ]
and they got to clean up your mess i
wish that genre of videos would just die
yeah but people just always
but that's the thing right it's like i
feel that a lot of the times like those
guys just get away with it oh yeah like
if there was like repercussions for
every single person who was doing that i
think it would stop you know obviously
but they just think like haha teehee i
just made a mess i think it's funny
right there was a video trend that went
around i have no idea why this is a
trend at all oh people used to open the
ice cream containers and lick it
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and someone to get convicted
actually oh yeah good luck that's
disgusting yeah it's [ __ ] vile yeah
it's so gross and i i have to sit there
and think what kind of
sick [ __ ]
thought of this idea and thought it was
funny and then also the person who
watched it and thought that's hilarious
yeah i'm gonna go do that
what's wrong
how have we failed every every single
parent on this earth how have they
failed there's two people who have the
same idea and thought this was funny and
then again after that more people find
it funny how are these people being bred
that that's just how i feel that's just
how i feel about like almost youtube all
like just internet that should be like
uh you know when you go to the doctor to
get your child birth they should play a
series of videos and they'll ask you is
this funny if you laugh at any of them
they just deny it yeah yeah yeah yeah
we're taking the kid
you clearly don't have the right child
services is just standing there like
waiting for you to laugh
it's like do it i like you all right
next up we have the uh screaming in
public challenge yeah here you go i
don't know if they laugh a little
show the tide pod challenge do you think
did you think that was a good idea
yeah how does it make you feel
i don't know
it's so tragic [ __ ] man we're a [ __ ]
person rorschach test that's terrible
did you ever find [ __ ] like jackass or
something funny back in the day though
yeah but that's because i think it was
it was new and it was unheard of and you
know as well when it was on tv there was
a lot of disconnect yeah i feel like
that disconnect from tv is just gone
because there was always like i don't
know as it might not have been true but
as a kid i was just if it was on tv then
there was always that disconnect of like
oh this is maybe staged or they sorted
something out it's or people in that
video got compensation of some form well
because you know when when jackass did
those stunts in public you know even
back then the rules were the same you
can't just upload any footage of any
person's face you have to get a release
form yeah so they were that means that
the person they pranked clearly signed
off on it yeah because you have to get
the release from or they've blurred yeah
and in that case it's like all right
well i like jackass back in the day but
like that tho the ones where they would
do [ __ ] in public with like just you
know random people in the streets i did
not like watching those just because
like i felt bad for the people who got
involved right what was it but i like
the ones where they would just like do
[ __ ] with each other and just laugh at
each other like those are [ __ ]
hilarious but yeah but you know also
that even with jackass right a network
is standing off on this they all
following rules right the problem is
with like when people are doing this in
public and they're doing it on their own
there's no rules there's no release
forms there's no procedure around this
and even if you aren't going to prank
someone you can't just show their face
like you have to get a release yeah like
it's it's it's a mess and uh i think the
problem is that because they've we've
seen this on tv the younger generation
think that oh okay well i can just do
that it's like no no no no no no
there's lots of adulting things there's
a reason why all the big prank channels
fake fake the stunt uh the pranks
because it gets the point otherwise they
can't get away with it yeah you can't
like getting release forms is a
nightmare and also you know getting the
even getting the reactions you want is a
pain in the ass and then you get you
have to get them to sign a release yeah
so it's it's
a lot of prank channels just are
[ __ ]
and they died yeah well nearly all of
them like a lot of them ran into trouble
like i mean
vitalia whatever was in prison
yeah yeah went to prison in egypt what
did he do he climbed the [ __ ]
pyramids oh yeah that's right
yeah and then and then when he got let
out he was like it's the worst thing
ever and then he got out and then went
and beat up some old woman
he jumped old woman in like santa monica
he actually went insane like he like
beat the he nearly killed this woman
[ __ ] i think i don't do pranks yeah
because i think the the the one story i
remember was like two kids uh oh that
was the two the two brothers who uh
who faked a like a burglary or something
like that or fake like
yeah and they got the uber yeah
then they got the uber and the uber
refused to drive them and they were like
what an [ __ ] uber driver who wouldn't
drive us and i was just like what what
is going on in this world right now and
they thought it was hilarious and the
people yeah and like millions of people
found that hilarious it's tragic yeah
and like you know that that prank where
that oh what a prank or that challenge
where that guy tried to uh see how many
if a book could stop a desert eagle or
something
which you know right you have to you
can't help but left and the ghost
girlfriend literally shot the boyfriend
she killed him and it's like it's like
this is tragic because like you know
people obviously getting these ideas
from watching this [ __ ] online it's
[ __ ] terrible i i think pranks are
generally just dodged
and any prank that isn't like a very
just like chill prank on like someone
you know
yeah you know those pranks are hilarious
right the ones the ones that always end
with the person getting pranked laughing
yeah is like you know the ones that are
like fine spray your housemate with
water you put a pie whatever that's all
good you know but like i just think when
you're doing it to strangers and they
have no say it's like and and it's
something that could hurt them or
something like genuinely scare them like
you could be traumatized if yeah some of
these absolutely
[ __ ] that no just like just like don't
be an [ __ ] basically it's it's it's
such a fine line because you know the
the line between a lot of psychopaths
they don't know what that
and uh you know unfortunately we live in
a climate where a lot of times being an
[ __ ] gives you good you're rewarded
you get rewarded for it yeah and it's
unfortunate man we're just like growing
into like old bitter old men aren't we i
just jesus man i don't know if it's
because i've just been on youtube so
long man that's just some genres i don't
like to be like elitist and look down on
genres of youtube yeah but pranks is one
of the challenges but then i do
but then i certainly will for the pranks
yeah absolutely that should have died
long ago i mean and luckily they have i
feel in a lot of ways but i i mean
they've died on youtube but now they've
just i think they've just migrated to
tickets
they they started on youtube and then
vine was also there was so many prank
vines as well and then now i think
they've just both migrated to tick-tock
as well and it's just i've been watching
a lot of youtube shorts and i just lose
my mind watching this stuff why are you
watching
it pops up and i watch them some of them
are funny something pretty good but
obviously just all reposts yeah yeah
yeah yeah but like there's some there's
like some genre videos that i just think
i absolutely despise to death and uh one
of them is like this is genre i don't
understand it at all
oh this is video and there's this guy
right and there's like imagine that your
phone is vertical whatever it's cut into
two
there'll be one video of the guy
explaining the video that is about to
play before you
okay that is very self-explanatory right
right so there's one where there was
this video and he was like this guy's
like here are the different types of
pokemon compared to each other in size
and it goes like pikachu one meter
snorlax one minute
wail lord and it's like i did not need
you to tell me what this is and i don't
need you to sit there for 10 seconds
like this
while the video is playing after you've
explained
screaming he's still on screen the whole
time he's just sitting there he's like
and then he'll go like whoa that's big
well i didn't expect that pokemon to be
big and it's like what is this what is
this you saw someone else's video you
reposted it oh it's not even his video
no and no no it's no of course it's not
his video and just repost it and it's
like this is [ __ ] this is the worst type
of content i hate this so much it's
literally just stealing i just hate it
man yeah it's terrible i i i reaction
reactions 2.0 the evolution this is what
it because yeah that's what it is
instead of like it's reaction videos
with somehow less they've made reaction
videos that are somehow worse than
reaction yeah where they're like not
even reacting it's like hey i'm going to
explain to you what the video is going
to explain to you
they're literally just a talking
description box yeah it's that's all it
is actually i i immediately skipped them
whenever or any like financial advice
ones i skip immediately there's a lot of
those there's a lot of ones that start
off with inspirational music you'll be
scrolling but you'll hear the
inspirational music here's how i made my
first million dollars
sir why are you working for ten dollars
an hour and it's like i know this is
going and it's like i work for one
thousand dollars an hour you know why i
value my time and it's oh my [ __ ] god
this is the the sheer amount of guru
stuff yeah tick tock and and youtube
shorts it's insane it's way out of
control well yeah i mean like it's it's
all kids you're gonna think that like
everyone should be earning 10 grand a
minute you know what i mean like they're
like
they go back to their dad you know and
their kids like what do you want to do
for christmas or what do you want to do
with the rest of your life kid comes in
with a [ __ ] bluetooth headset dad
i've already started making ten thousand
dollars an hour from drop shipping
online you know the fact that you're
working at your job is actually kind of
cringe dad
you know what i mean it's like
like you're gonna have a whole
generation of kids race like this tragic
they're in love like [ __ ]
kindergartens like putting down what
they want to be when they grow up and
everyone puts entrepreneur
entrepreneurs that's like what do you
want for christmas son dad why haven't
you invested in my 401k this is
embarrassing
when you grow up where would you like to
go silicon valley
the only destination it's [ __ ] absurd
it's so stupid man
i can't stand this just do what you want
man just do what you want there's a lot
of really funny stuff there on there but
you have to you've just siphoned and
shoveled through so much [ __ ] yeah to
find some good tick tocks that's why i
just wait for them to eventually get
onto twitter yeah yeah
you know if they like like make their
way on like youtube compilations or
twitter which is how i consume most of
my tic toc because i did i i did
actually try downloading tick tock uh
the other day and i gave it a go and i
was just like
oh it's just
i i'm i'm i'm i don't have enough
patience for the algorithm to find what
i've really liked because there's so
much [ __ ] you go through and there's
like it's so weird seeing some of the
tick tocks that are there because i
remember
i remember i remember going through
animatic talk right and seeing okay i'm
i am i am an anime youtuber i trade i
wonder what anime tick tock is uh is up
to that was your first
mistake asking that question so so there
was this like really really weird trend
that was going on which is like the
silhouette trend or something like that
right i remember that [ __ ] okay okay so
you know you know what i'm talking about
well like we're like these girls or guys
would like basically
pretend that they were making out with a
silhouette of a character or something
right yeah and one of those funny
i'm wondering not really but it's just
like it's 100 serious it's ironic oh
it's ironically funny oh i thought i
thought
just pretend like you're making out with
someone right and it's like there's no
irony to it it is just
it is just that yeah and i remember i
was browsing anime tick tock and i saw a
clip which had like millions and
millions of views on this clip and it's
this and then there's this girl who's
pretending to make up with a silhouette
of barkago and they literally look they
literally put in sound clips of the dub
to make it seem like he's like uh he's
in a he's in a dominating fashion
for this tick tock and i'm just like
i must be getting old because i remember
i remember if you did this like when i
was an anime fan growing up you'd get
bullied for this you would get chris you
would like this like this is the type of
[ __ ] pretty good people got internet
bullied for man i like the jojo post
wrong it's like jojo jojo was cool that
one was cool that was cool because it
was like yeah because like there was
either people who were just really good
at jojo posting but then there were
other people who like took that and put
like a spin on it right with like all
sorts of different anime and stuff
that's fine but like that [ __ ] is the
same as like you know like laughing at
those is the same as people you know
laughing like back in the day of like
you know watching people proposing at
anime cons and stuff like that right
like those like that trend of video it's
just like kind of coming back but now
it's just on tick tock now yeah yeah and
it's it's just so weird seeing these
things trending and being popular
because i just remember thinking
wow like this is
so much different to being an anime fan
when i was [ __ ] yeah when i was like
they just like post anime scenes and
like play different music yeah and i'm
like what is this what i don't wanna
watch this [ __ ]
i've seen this repost of this one anime
scene a million times and it's some
samurai versus like a lumberjack
what and they're like fighting each
other okay and i've seen this scene
reposted on youtube and tick tock and
stuff like a million times i still don't
know what it's from right but i've seen
this fight like a million times and it's
just always on tick tock i don't get it
is it like good at all yeah it's pretty
cool okay that's it
they just keep reposting it like i don't
get it
at least it's not like the samurai
lumberjack making out right in the
silhouette challenge
it could
it like gave me the same reaction as you
know the that animation of like sonic
and mario making
that's a great
it's it's that one has like so many
layers to it though you know fiery
passion at which
uh mario and sonic are making out and
sonic rips off mario's like
shirt and like such a passion yeah yeah
that makes me feel like they are in love
it's so funny it's amazing
god yeah just i don't know man like i
tried downloading tick tock because like
users ticked off quite a bit we sound
like boomers here
i'm trying to get understanding i tried
it i tried just because i saw it was
getting so big so i was like all right
well then you know if it because it is
getting so big there might be a chance
one of these days i might have to start
using it right yeah i i scrolled through
it and i just feel like i'm losing my
mind yeah i feel like my mind is going
numb watching this stuff because it's so
fast-paced you don't get a chance to do
anything you don't just like think you
just all right next next it's just it's
like literally just constantly just
watching instagram stories yeah yeah i'm
like i can't do it i never felt like so
much information i was in like a black
mirror thing until i was watching
youtube shorts yeah and tick tock
because like
you don't even like you're not even
watching the videos you're just like
consuming the videos yeah yeah you
scroll the next one scroll the next one
you don't even think you just scroll
keep scrolling you don't and like on
youtube at least you have that thing of
like well i'm going to look what i want
to watch that wasn't the good okay
page all right refresh the homepage look
at the brow you know you have to
actually think what you're about to
watch yeah but on tick tock and shorts
they just feed it to you yeah and you
don't think it's weird right like i feel
like we're getting to the point where
content is being forced down your throat
it's like not what you're choosing to
watch right right i mean there's
there's some content on tick tock which
was just so
weird because it's like it was almost
like hypnotic because there was some
there's some content that it's just like
had obviously like millions and millions
of views and it's just like some very
oddly satisfying thing or something or
something i don't know it's it's so hard
to describe why
i was like
not invested but just like
intrigued by it yeah but i wouldn't call
it like interesting content it was just
like oh that's uh entrenched couldn't
take your ideas that's a bit that's
that's a bit interesting all right and
next oh oh okay that's that's pretty
good right
it wasn't like i was never like
emotionally invested in any of this
content which is why i kind of felt like
almost hypnotic in a way because it
doesn't give you the time to get
emotionally invested right because it's
over in six seconds yeah i mean i've
like i've the only funny tick tocks i've
seen i've been tick tocks that have just
like made its way into twitter or
youtube composition yeah yeah like on
tick tock i don't know what i'm doing
wrong well how how do i how do you tic
talk how do i make tick tock good i want
to know i want to know where to find a
good content because you can't search
like you can't search for anything like
you can but you have to sift through
just like if you look up like a hashtag
right that if you happen to find one or
like an audio file or something that you
thought was kind of funny that's been
used right like you can search for that
but in order to find like the actual
gucci you just have to sift through so
much unrelated [ __ ] i had like a few
audios of mine like get pretty big yeah
like from my youtube videos i was just
like what the [ __ ] is this because it
was like really bizarre things like
there was one where it was about me like
saying sucking dick or something yeah
and cosplay and it like those so many
people who used it to make tick tocks i
was so confused because it was like he's
like 13 year old kids being like there's
no time to talk i need to wear cosplay
and suck dick or something and i'm like
is this okay
what is going on i'm so confused and i
was like okay uh hopefully people don't
watch my videos uh because some of these
kids look really young yeah it's yeah
i've had a couple of things yeah i've
had a couple of tick tocks where they've
used my audio i like it though i think
it's interesting it's it's really cool
because it's like oh that's you know
that's kind of flattering that they
thought it was funny though i just feel
like i think look at it i'm like yeah
what's going on but yeah but at the same
time i'm like that's cool but at the
same time i look at i'm like why are you
doing this
well i just thought i was thinking i was
like surely i've said other things in in
an order that are more entertaining and
more useful than that like of all the
things i've said you thought this one
was yeah yeah
i mean that's how the internet is right
it just takes things off i don't know i
don't know it's weird we don't we don't
know how to tick talk yeah
have you ever like legitimately thought
being like i need to start a tick tock
no
i mean i i'd like because there's lots
of youtubers right now who are like i
don't know
i'm not convinced the tick tock audience
is
well the demographic i want right i
don't know i like the demographic i have
right now yeah i like just chill and do
mine things streaming games i mean it's
it's like i think we've grown up we've
brought we've like made an audience that
like us for us luckily enough and like
the content we make i don't feel like i
need to move myself on a different
platform just because that platform is
getting popular right it's kind of like
yeah we've definitely grown with that
well our audience has grown with us yeah
it's kind of like why i i get so many
messages about this about god why don't
you use instagram why don't why don't
you post more on instagram
it's the simple answer of i just i'm
[ __ ] at taking photos okay i just forget
to document my life i'm sorry i feel
that okay and it's just you know i'm
that's why i get my girlfriend to take
photos of me because i'm so [ __ ] at
taking photos of myself
and it's just like you know you you get
brands coming to be like oh instagram's
the you know instagram for the most
viewers and the most like audience and
the biggest numbers and i'm just like
well is that really valuable just going
on a platform just because it's got big
numbers and a big audience or is it like
as a content creator i find it's way
more valuable even if you're promoting
to a smaller audience that it's an
audience that is more suitable for the
stuff that you're making right right so
i'm not going to make a tick tock just
because it's popular unless i think i
actually like tick tock well i think i
can make good tick tocks you know
because otherwise i'm going to get a
bunch of audience that i don't
understand or yeah
and then
and then and then i will literally be
the boomer that yeah you know just like
oh let's let's connect with the kids
everyone's having a tick tock nowadays
let's make a tick tock of me making out
with bark
maybe i would take off
like maybe i could do it making out with
but you know who else has a tick tock or
who doesn't have to take our patrons i
don't know i i tried to [ __ ] terrible
outro shout out to the patrons
uh i don't do terrible outros
i tried to somehow segue here from
you know that you know that group of
audience members that do this thing but
also don't do this thing these guys
pretty sure like the [ __ ] you you rode
the segway and just [ __ ] crashed into
the train crashed into the [ __ ] right
off
but hey if you'd like to uh join the
patreon and support the show then make
sure to go over to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us your memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify yeah
and uh yeah that's been pretty much the
boomer episode of smash taste
uh we are getting old i i i thought i'm
20 i'm 25 man
quarter of a century olds i prefer to
say wow look look at this baby look at
this baby i've probably aged mentally
the most yeah you are you are the
closest to death i've been considering
getting a lawn mower that i can sit on
uh
to be fair there are times where i'm
like that looks lit
oh you know if i'm getting along i'm
getting a lot more i could say hell yeah
dude with a slot for my my tic toc phone
enables
so i can watch all the people meeting
yeah
on my oled 4k phone
you know you know how like you know the
first time i felt old
the first time i got a bonus trash taste
trash taste wherever i just i just need
to say this first time i got excited
about buying furniture i was like yep
it's over for me but like now now that
i'm moving god damn i'm so excited to
re-furnish my place
dude when that new washing machine came
in i was like dude [ __ ] the hype i felt
for all these games this is where the
real hype is at dude
manage
i can't wait to do it properly i've done
it wrong anyway are you keeping up with
us
anyway will continue this on the next
trash taste when we are moved in thanks
for watching guys and we'll see you next
time
[Music]
you